QUORUM I THINK WERE ONE SHY OF A
QUORUM -- I WANNA WELCOME.
MISS COM LARGER DEAF TO OUR
INSURANCE [inaudible]
COMMITTEE.
MR VOEPEL IS ALSO HAS RETURNED
TO THE INSURANCE COMMITTEE
ALTHOUGH IS NOT HERE YET
[inaudible]
SO.
THANK YOU MISTER COOLEY -- YEAH
THERE ARE OTHER COMMITTEES --
OCCURRING RIGHT NOW SO THAT'S
ONE ONE JUST.
ONE MR COOLEY LEAPS INTO ACTION
ACTION.
ELECTIONS.
FOR AND WE GO ALL RIGHT WE CAN
GET.
OUT OF IT WE THERE IS LITTLE
GAME.
ONE MR CHIU YOU SAVE THE DAY.
SO LET'S SIR.
LET'S CALL THE MEETING TO ORDER
OFFICIALLY AND TAKE ROLE IN
ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
DAILY.
HERE MAYES HERE BERMAN HERE.
BIGELOW.
ALL THE RUN [inaudible] TEN
YEARS [inaudible] TWO COOLEY
HERE.
COOPER.
FRAZIER PRESENT.
GIPSON [inaudible]
GRAYSON [inaudible]
KAMLAGER-DOVE THERE [inaudible]
VOEPEL [inaudible]
REALLY.
THANK.
YOU TO FOR WE HAVE A QUORUM.
AND WELCOME WELCOME MISTER
COOPER.
ALSO WANT TO WELCOME MISTER
BERMAN TO THE COMMITTEE -- WE
APPRECIATE YOU JOINING OUR
COMMITTEE AND YOU HAVE A BILL TO
PRESENT LET'S GET ROLLING HERE
GO AHEAD MR BERMAN GREAT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
COLLEAGUES.
CALIFORNIA IS UNIQUE IN MANY
WAYS AND AND OFTEN THIS IS A
GOOD THING.
HOWEVER IF THE LAW ALLOWING
ELECTRONIC INSURANCE
TRANSACTIONS WERE TO SUNSET.
WHAT WE WANT TO BE THE ONLY
STATE TO NOT ALLOW SUCH
TRANSACTIONS?
ONLY AB TEN SIXTY FIVE WHAT
INDEFINITELY EXTEND THE ABILITY
OF INSURERS TO OFFER CONSUMERS
THE OPTION OF ELECTRONIC
TRANSACTIONS.
THE COMMITTEE CONSULTANTS
ANALYSIS DOES AN EXCELLENT JOB
DETAILING THE ADVANTAGES OF
HAVING ELECTRONIC TRANSACTIONS
AS AN OPTION.
INCLUDING CONSUMER CHOICE FASTER
DELIVERY REDUCED COST IT'S
GREENER AFFORDABILITY AND
ACCESSIBILITY IN THE WAKE OF
DISASTERS.
HOWEVER BECAUSE WE ARE DEALING
WITH IMPORTANT NOTICE TO
CONSUMERS THE LAW IMPOSES
ADDITIONAL SAFEGUARDS ON
INSURERS. FOR EXAMPLE A CONSUMER
MUST ACKNOWLEDGE RECEIPT OF
SENSITIVE DOCUMENTS TRANSMITTED
ELECTRONICALLY.
SO THAT I MISSED EMAIL OR AN
EMAIL THAT AND THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES.
OF THAT ENDS UP CAUGHT AS SPAM
FILTER WILL NOT JEOPARDIZE
INSURANCE COVERAGE THE
HEIGHTENED STANDARD OF CONSUMER
PROTECTION IS FAR GREATER.
THAN THE LAW APPLICABLE FOR
PAPER DOCUMENTATION AB TEN SIXTY
FIVE WOULD RETAIN ALL CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS WHILE PERMANENTLY
PRESERVING THE OPTION FOR
CONSUMER TO CHOOSE ELECTRONIC
TRANSMISSION.
OF INSURANCE DOCUMENTATION AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
AND I HAVE A COUPLE OF EXPERTS
WITH ME TODAY.
COMMENTS GO AHEAD MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS JOHN STREAKING
ASSOCIATION A CALIFORNIA LIFE
INSURANCE COMPANIES WANT TO
THINK IS A MEMBER OF AN FOR
KAREN'S APARTMENT JR.
WE CONTINUE TO HEAR FROM OUR
POLICY HOLDERS THAT THEY WOULD
LIKE THE BILL WOULD RECEIVE
CERTAIN DOCUMENTS ELECTRONICALLY
SO IT'S A SIMPLE REMOVAL OF A
SUNSET.
WE THINK IT'S A GOOD BILL ON
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
SEC CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE OUR MONTHLY SEE ON ON
BEHALF THE MACON PROPERTY
CASUALTY INSURERS ASSOCIATION --
WE WANT TO THANK US AND THE
MEMBER BERMAN FOR A SPONSORING A
BILL I'LL BE VISUALLY SUPPORTED
THIS AND WE THINK THIS IS GOING
TO GO A LONG WAY FOR MEMBERS TO
INVEST IN THIS -- TECHNOLOGIES
THANK YOU.
GOOD THANK YOU OTHER A FOLKS IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL GOOD MORNING
SHERRY MCCUE REPRESENTING THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION IMAGE OF
INSURANCE AND FINANCIAL ADVISORS
AND THE PACIFIC ASSOCIATION OF
DOMESTIC INSURANCE COMPANIES AND
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING CAM STONE STONE
ADVOCACY ON BEHALF OF ALL STATE
INSURANCE IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING SEVEN TAYLOR FOR
THE PERSONAL INSURANCE
FEDERATION OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT.
HI MARIA GARCIA ON BEHALF OF
STATE FARM INSURANCE AND SUPPORT.
ANY OTHERS SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
AWESOME [inaudible]
GOOD.
THAT'S EVEN BETTER THAN SPEAKING
IT IS -- ARE THERE ANY OTHER ANY
FOLKS WHO WISH.
TO OPPOSE THE BILL OR AS MY
FRIEND MISTER MEDINA LIKES TO
SAY OR LEADERS ARE NO TWEENER
SEE CALLS BETWEEN HERS.
NO TWEETERS NO OPPOSITION.
OF COMMITTEE MEMBERS ANY
QUESTIONS FOR MISTER BERMAN.
THERE'S A MOTION.
MS CALL MUGGER DOVE HI MISTER
BERMAN I HAD A QUESTION AND
MAYBE YEAR EXPERTS COULD -- HELP
SHARE WITH US JUST WONDERING
SINCE THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS
NEW KIND OF WAY OF SHARING
INFORMATION WITH CONSUMERS WHAT
HAS THE INDUSTRY LEARNED.
ABOUT THE ABILITY TO BOTH MANAGE
PAPER.
KIND OF CONSUMPTION BY CONSUMERS
AND ALSO MANAGING -- THE
SECURITY OF THAT OF
DOCUMENTATION AND INFORMATION.
CHURN HAPPY TO TAKE THAT
QUESTION AND THANK YOU SOMETHING
MEMBER.
AT WE CONTINUE HERE FROM AND
THERE'S A REPORT THAT WILL --
THAT WAS REQUIRED WHEN WE DID
THIS BILL THE FIRST TIME AROUND
THAT'LL BE FORTHCOMING FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE AND AND
THAT'LL GIVE US A DEEPER LOOK
INTO -- EXACTLY HOW THIS IS
WORKED BUT FROM OUR END WE
HAVEN'T HEARD COMPLAINTS FROM
POLICY HOLDERS WERE ACTUALLY
HEARING THAT OPPOSITE WERE.
CONTINUALLY GET REQUEST TO ALLOW
DOCTORS TO BE DELIVERED
ELECTRONICALLY -- WE HAVE
SAFEGUARDS IN THERE I KNOW THERE
WAS A CONCERN THAT SOME OF THIS
MIGHT EITHER GO TO JUNK MAIL OR
MY SHIP TURNED.
IN THOSE INSTANCES WE DO HAVE
SAFEGUARDS -- YOU WOULD DEFAULT
TO HAVE PAPER -- DELIVERY SHOULD
THAT HAPPEN SO WE HAVE THE
SAFEGUARDS IN PLACE IT'S WORKING
WELL FROM OUR AND WILL I THINK
THE REPORT NOT DEPARTMENT
CHARGED WILL SHOW THAT AS WELL --
SO AGAIN THIS IS JUST A QUICK
REMOVAL OF IT WE WANT FOLKS.
TO INVESTMENTS TECHNOLOGY WE
WANT TO BE ABLE TO MEET THE
DEMANDS OF OUR CONSUMERS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS FOR MISTER
BERMAN OR HIS.
WITH THE SPONSORS.
IF NOT -- THERE'S A MOTION AND
SECOND LET'S VOTE. EIGHT EIGHT
AND SIXTY FIVE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS.
DALY AYE DALY AYE MAYES AYE
MAYES AYE BERMAN.
HI BERMAN AYE BIGELOW.
CALDERON HI HOLD ON I CHEN.
CHEN I CHIU AYE CHU AYE COOLEY
AYE COOLEY AYE COOPER HI COOPER
I FRAZIER.
FRAZIER I GIPSON.
GIPSON I GRAYSON.
KAMLAGER-DOVE HI KAMLAGER-DOVE I
VOEPEL. ELEVEN ZERO ALL RIGHT.
ELEVEN ZERO NICE WORK MISSED
BERMAN THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WE HAVE SIX
ITEMS ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
LET'S GO AHEAD IN -- MOTION AND
SECOND TO APPROVE THE CONSENT
CALENDAR ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
LET'S GO AHEAD AND VOTE ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
DALY HI DALY AYE NAY.
MAYES AYE BERMAN.
BERMAN AYE BIGELOW.
CALDERON CALDERON AYE CHAN.
CHAN I TO TO AYE COOLEY AYE
COOLEY AYE COOPER AYE COOPER AYE
FRAZIER.
FRAZIER I GIPSON.
GIPSON I GRAYSON.
KAMLAGER-DOVE HI KAMLAGER-DOVE I
VOEPEL [inaudible] ELEVEN ZERO
GREAT -- I HAVE TWO BILLS TO
PRESENT AT ALL WAIT TILL THE END
OF OUR HEARING TO DO THAT --
MISTER CALDERON IF YOU WANT TO
PRESENT YOUR BILL THIS IS A
WE'VE ALREADY WE'VE ALREADY
APPROVED ONE OF YOUR BILLS
MISTER CALDERON WHICH WAS ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR [inaudible]
YES SIR.
OKAY YOU KNOW MY MISTAKE YOU DO
HAVE TO BILLS TO PRESENT FIVE
SIX SEVEN ALSO.
YEAH.
SORRY ABOUT THAT NO [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS AB LEVEL FOR
WILL ADD TO PUBLIC MEMBERS TO
THE BOARD OF THE CALIFORNIA LIFE
AND HEALTH INSURANCE GUARANTY
ASSOCIATION OTHER WHAT THE WISE
KNOWN AS CLEA -- AND CREATE AN
ASSESSMENT TO FIND FINANCIAL
OVERSIGHT OF LONG TERM CARE
INSURANCE COMPANIES I'VE WORKED
A LOT OF LONG TERM CARE
INSURANCE.
PROVIDERS ARE VERY MUCH SEE THIS
ISSUE AS A MILLENNIAL ISSUE
BECAUSE OF THE OUR PARENTS THAT
WENT THROUGH THE RECESSION LOST
THEIR HOMES AND LOST A LOT OF
THEIR FINANCIAL SECURITY FOR
RETIREMENT.
ALL RIGHT NOW KLAY GOT EXIST TO
MAKE SURE THAT IF HEALTH AND
SURE OUR LONG TERM CARE PROVIDER
GOES UNDER ALL THE INSURANCE
COMPANIES COME IN. TO FIND THE
THE POLICIES THAT THOSE.
INDIVIDUALS THAT HAVE POLICIES
WITH THAT ONE A COMPANY THAT
NGUYEN UNDER -- THAT MAKE SURE
THAT THEY GET THE BENEFITS THAT
THEY PAID FOR ALL RIGHT NOW THE
CLEAR THE BOARD IS MADE UP OF
ONLY INSURANCE INDUSTRY FOLKS
THIS WOULD ADD TWO MORE
POSITIONS.
OF NON INSURANCE INDUSTRY
INDIVIDUALS GOOD BELL OBVIOUSLY
IMPORTANT ISSUE AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE --
WITH ME TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
TODAY'S JOHN TRICK IN -- WITH
ACT LIKE.
GO AHEAD SIR THANK CHAIRMAN
BRIDGE JOSH FREAKING THE
DISSOCIATION A CALIFORNIA LIFE
AND HEALTH INSURANCE COMPANIES.
AB ELEVEN BEFORE AS A FOLLOW UP
TO A BILL WE WORKED ON LAST YEAR
AB TWENTY THREE NINETY FIVE
WHICH SEEKS TO GIVE GREATER
TRANSPARENCY AND OVERSIGHT.
INTO -- LONG TERM CARE INSURANCE
INDUSTRY -- AS MISTER CALDERON
STATED -- SO THAT TWO NEW --
PUBLIC MEMBERS TO THE CLIPBOARD.
AND AS WELL -- AUTHORIZING
ASSESSMENT BY DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE FOR THEM TO CARRY OUT
THEIR WORDS I DUTIES -- WE THINK
THIS IS A GOOD IMPORTANT FIRST
STEP -- TO UNDERSTANDING THE
WORLD A LONG TERM CARE A LITTLE
BIT MORE WEEKS RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR I WILL.
ARE THERE QUESTIONS SIR.
LET ME OPEN IT UP OF EXCUSE ME
GO HEAD -- NO THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING MICHAEL MARTINEZ SENIOR
DEPUTY COMMISSIONER OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE HERE FOR
INSURANCE COMMISSIONER RICARDO
LARA.
AND THAT WE ARE -- PROBABLY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE AND TO
FEEL THAT IT CAN THAT'S WHAT TO
THE AUTHOR AND TO WHAT MISTER
SHAKING HAD SAID THAT THIS WOULD
ALLOW THE DEPARTMENT TO BE ABLE --
TO PEOPLE TO RECOUP THE COSTS
SINCE IN THE OVERSIGHT
RESPONSIBILITIES THAT IT HAS FOR
THIS IMPORTANT WORK.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR SPEAKING ON BEHALF
OF THE DEPARTMENT THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE.
ARE THERE OTHER FOLKS WHO LIKE
TO SPEAK IN FAVOR THIS BILL.
MOVIE ITEM. SEVEN YEAH IT'S
ALREADY IT'S ARE WE THE MANAGER.
I GUESS FOR STARTING A VOTE
ALREADY.
I JUMPED IMPRISONMENT COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MISTER COOLEY MICHAEL
WELCOME BACK MICHAEL'S WORK THE
INSURANCE ISSUES FOR MANY MANY
YEARS HE'S A GREAT ASSET TO THE
PROCESS OF MAINTENANCE AND FOR
THE COMMITTEE AND TELL.
HIM YOU HAVE.
WE ARE CO THAT.
ANY QUESTIONS ON THE BILL.
IF NOT LET'S GO AHEAD VOTE.
ON EIGHTY FIVE SIXTY SEVEN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO AGING AND
LONG TERM CARE.
DALY BY DALY AYE MAYES AYE MAYES
AYE BERMAN.
BERMAN AYE BIGELOW.
CALDERON HI WALDRON AYE CHAN.
CHAN I CHIU.
CHU AYE COOLEY AYE COOLEY AYE
COOPER.
COOPER I FRAZIER [inaudible]
FRAZIER I GIPSON.
SEN I GRAYSON [inaudible]
KAMLAGER-DOVE [inaudible]
I HONG KAMLAGER-DOVE I VOEPEL.
ELEVEN ZERO ELEVEN ZERO MISTER.
YES I'M JUST TO CLARIFY THAT WAS
FOR A BI -- ELEVEN FOR NEXT BILL
UP IS FIVE SIX SEVEN OKAY.
MY FAULT I A A I CONFUSED
EVERYONE [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
SO THAT WAS.
ELEVEN OH FOUR RIGHT EVERYONE'S
CLEAR AND NOW WILL MOVE TO AB
FIVE SIX SEVEN THANK YOU GUYS.
FIVE THANK YOU MEMBERS AB FIVE
SIX SEVEN ESTABLISHES A LONG
TERM CARE INSURANCE TASK FORCE
CONVENED BY THE INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER THE PURPOSE OF THE
TASK FORCE IS TO PROVIDE EXPERT
RECOMMENDATIONS THE INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER THE LEGISLATURE.
AND THE GOVERNOR ON THE
COMPONENTS NECESSARY TO
ESTABLISH A STATE WIDE LONG TERM
CARE INSURANCE PROGRAM.
GIVE IN THE GROWING RECOGNITION
OF CALIFORNIA'S DEMOGRAPHIC
SHIFTS IT IS AN OPPORTUNE TIME
TO RESEARCH AND IDENTIFY
STRATEGIES AVAILABLE TO CHART A
SUCCESSFUL PATH FOR LONG TERM
CARE STABILITY.
THERE USED TO BE WELL OVER A
HUNDRED PROVIDERS A LONG TERM
CARE INSURANCE IN THIS COUNTRY
NOW THAT'S SLOWLY NESTERS TWELVE
ONE JUST WENT UNDER -- NOT TOO
LONG AGO SO THE LESS --
PROVIDERS WE HAVE THE HIGHER THE
COST -- AND ALSO -- THE LACK OF
STABILITY THAT THE INSURANCE A
LONG TERM CARE INSURANCE MARKET
HAS SO WE NEED TO FIGURE OUT
OTHER OPTIONS MOVING FORWARD TO
MAKE SURE WE PROVIDE THAT.
LONG TERM CARE INSURANCE --
OPTION -- AND SO THAT'S THE
POINT OF THIS TASK FORCE WITH ME
TO TESTIFY SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
I AM WITH ME TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT IS STILL OUR DELORES
DERON FLOOR AS FROM THE
CALIFORNIA EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION
GOOD MORNING MR MEMBERS MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS I'M TO OUR
STRAND FLOORS CALIFORNIA'S
WELCOME WAYS ASSOCIATION.
WE ARE HERE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL -- WE REPRESENT TUNER FORTY
THOUSAND CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES
ACROSS THE STATE MANY OF THESE
EMPLOYEES ARE VERY LOW INCOME.
ARE THERE LOW EARNERS INCOME
EARNERS MAKING ABOUT ELEVEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR IS PART
TIMERS TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS A YEAR IS FULL TIMERS
MANY OF THEM WORK JUST FOR THEIR
HEALTH CARE.
THIS LONG TERM CARE INSURANCE IS
OFTEN OUT OF THEIR INCOME
ABILITY TO PAY SO WE SUPPORT
THIS BILL MANY OF OUR MEMBERS IN
A RETIREE UNITS HAVE RETIRED
HAVE LONG TERM HEALTH INSURANCE
BUT THEY STRUGGLE TO PAY FOR IT
BECAUSE THEY HAVE THE INCREASES
THAT COM -- EVERY YEAR SO WE'RE
LOOKING AT THIS BILLS AN
IMPORTANT.
A BILL THAT WILL HELP WORKING
FAMILIES AND WE ARE THREE ABOUT.
THANK YOU.
AND MISTER CALDERON YOU HAVE
OTHER.
FOLKS IN SUPPORT.
MY WONDERFUL STAFFERS STEP IN
THIS BILL OKAY DEANNA YOU CAN
LETTER SPEAK.
OKAY IT'S OKAY IT'S OKAY -- NOW
THAT HE'S TURNING RED SORRY
ABOUT THAT.
M. ANY.
OTHER FOLKS WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
ANY FOLKS SPEAKING IN OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS DO YOU HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FOR
MISTER CALDERON.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS IF NOT WE
HAVE A MOTION AND SECOND.
ANY YOUR CLOSING REMARKS MISTER
CALDERON THANK YOU MEMBERS FOR
YOUR TIME AS CHAIR RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR MY VOTE OKAY LET'S VOTE.
ON EIGHTY FIVE SIXTY SEVEN THE
MOTION AS DO PASSED THE AGING
AND LONG TERM CARE -- DAILY AYE
DALY AYE MAYES AYE MAYES AYE
BERMAN.
I BIGELOW.
BIGELOW I CALLED RUN BY CALDERON
I CHEN.
CHEN AYE CHIU.
CHU AYE COOLEY AYE COOLEY AYE
COOPER -- FOR I FRAZIER.
FRAZIER I GIPSON.
GIPSON I GRAYSON.
KAMLAGER-DOVE HI KAMLAGER-DOVE I
VOEPEL [inaudible] ZERO TWELVE
TO ZERO THAT BILL.
MOVES ON TO ITS NEXT STEP
[inaudible]
AND MR COOLEY WOULD YOU LIKE TO
TALK ABOUT THE BILL.
THAT YOU PULLED.
BEFORE WHILE WE'RE WAITING FOR
MR LOW TO COME FORWARD.
TO MISTER COOLEY GO AHEAD AND
TALK ABOUT ITEM THREE IF YOU'D
LIKE.
YES COLLEAGUES -- IN THE WAKE OF
THE DYNAMICS DECISION.
I INTRODUCED A JUST WAIT.
MR TOOL IS ADDRESSING A ITEM
THREE WHICH SHE'S PULLED FROM
THE CALENDAR.
YEAH COLLEAGUES I I INTRODUCED
AB.
TWO THIRTY THREE IN THE WAKE OF
THE DYNAMICS DECISION.
DEALING WITH WAGE ORDERS -- IN
AS MUCH AS IT HAS IMPLICATIONS.
FOR GIG ECONOMY BUT ACTUALLY
ENTIRE ECONOMY.
AB TWO THIRTY THREE WAS FOCUSED
ON THE INSURANCE ASPECTS OF IT.
INSURANCE IS.
AMONG OUR STATE.
WELL WE'RE IT WHERE THE BRICKS
INSURANCE MARKET IN THE NATION.
INSURANCE.
IS LONG REGULATED BY THE STATE.
IT IS SUBJECT TO THE DEFINITION
OF AGENCY ACTION WAS ADOPTED IN
THIS STATE IN EIGHTEEN SEVENTY
THREE WE'VE HAD STATE BASED
REGULAR SINCE THE EIGHTEEN
EIGHTIES.
ARE THE MCCARRAN FERGUSON ACT
ADOPTED NINETEEN FORTY FIVE ALL
INSURANCE REGULATIONS STATE
BASED.
IS A PART OF A NATIONAL SYSTEM
OF REGULATION.
DONE TO THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION
OF INSURANCE COMMISSIONERS.
WHICH ADMINISTERS A TAXATION
SYSTEM KNOWS RETALIATORY
TAXATION WHICH MAKES INSURANCE
AGENCY.
THE ONLY USE OF AGENCY IN OUR
CALIFORNIA STATE CONSTITUTION
IT'S A TERM IN ARTICLE THREE
SECTION TWENTY STATE
CONSTITUTION ANYWAY.
SO I WAS CONCERNED THAT THE
DYNAMICS DECISION FAILED TO TAKE
ACCOUNT OF THE MORE THAN
CENTURIES.
OUR STATE BASED REGULATION
INSURANCE TRANSACTIONS AND
AGENCY GENERALLY.
ARE AS SB AS AB FIVE HAS
PROCEEDED -- IT IS RECENT BEEN
BEEN AMENDED IN A WAY THAT WOULD
ADDRESS.
MY CONCERNS WITH THE DECISION
AND INSURANCE BUSINESS.
WE HAVE AN EXCELLENT ANALYSIS
PREPARED BY OUR COMMITTEE OF MY
BILLS LAYS OUT THE HISTORY AND
DISTINCT INNOCENT INSURANCE
BUSINESS.
I'M PULLING MY BILL I WILL
ACTUALLY MINUTES WAS STOLEN OR
DYNAMICS BILL.
AND BUT I INTEND TO KEEP AN EYE
ON THIS ISSUE AS A WOULD AFFECT --
DISRUPTION INSURANCE BUSINESS IF
IT'S IF THE TRUCKER GOING ON NOW
IS NOT CONTINUE.
THANK YOU MISTER COOLEY IT'S
SUCHA IMPORTANT TOPICAL ISSUE I
WANTED TO GIVE YOU AN
OPPORTUNITY.
TO COMMENT AND GIVE THE MEMBERS
A STATUS THANK ON THAT SUBJECT
THANK YOU AGAIN MR COOLEY.
NOW MISTER LOWE IS HERE ON A. B..
NINE THIRTY TWO THE BILL GO
AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MR MEMBERS LET ME
JUST FIRST SAY THAT THIS IS MY
VERY FIRST TIME BEFORE THIS
COMMITTEE SO -- IN MY FIVE YEARS
HERE I BELIEVE FIVE THREE BILLS
THIS YEAR SO I JUST WANT TO SAY
HOW WONDERFUL IT IS TO SEE WE
INTEND TO TREAT YOU.
AS WELL AS WE CAN.
AND ALSO I'LL SAY NO MORE WILL
TREAT YOU WELL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
IN TWO THOUSAND AND SEVENTEEN A
GUNMAN OPENED FIRE IN LAS VEGAS.
DURING A MUSIC FESTIVAL OVER
FIVE HUNDRED PEOPLE WERE INJURED
AND FIFTY EIGHT PEOPLE DIED IN
THAT SHOOTING.
AT TWELVE OF CALIFORNIA'S
BRAVEST WERE SHOT IN THE COURSE
OF RENDERING AID -- DURING THIS
HORRIFICALLY VENTS UNFORTUNATELY
THESE FIREFIGHTERS WERE DOING
THEIR JOBS WELL.
I'M TRYING TO SAVE OTHERS BUT
WHERE THEY WERE NOT CALIFORNIA
SOIL OF THIS BILL ENSURES THAT
CALIFORNIA FIREFIGHTERS WERE
INJURED.
OUTSIDE OF THE STATE ARE ALSO
PROTECTED WITH RESPECT TO
WORKERS COMPENSATION.
ON THIS IS A FOLLOW UP TO THE
CHAIRS PREVIOUS BILL WITH
RESPECT TO A WORKER
COMPENSATIONS PROTECTIONS FOR
LAW ENFORCEMENT A WITH ME TODAY
IS MICHAEL CORDAGE A SAN
BERNARDINO COUNTY FIREFIGHTER.
WHO IS ACTUALLY AT THE LAS VEGAS
FEST AND SHOT?
WHILE GIVING CPR TO A VICTIM I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE IN
ASK FOR YOUR INDULGENCE IN
HEARING IS COMPELLING TESTIMONY.
SURE MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CHRIS
DEVELOP ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS POLICE TO BE
SPONSOR THIS MEASURE AND YIELD
MY TIME TO MIKE.
THANK YOU.
GO AHEAD SIR YES THANK YOU THANK
YOU CHAIRMAN DALY AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE FOR HEARING MY
TESTIMONY TODAY AND ASSEMBLY
BILL AND NINE THIRTY TWO MY NAME
IS MIKE COURT HM A FIREFIGHTER
FOR SENATE COUNTY FIRE
DEPARTMENT I WORK IN THE CPAP.
SPECIAL OPERATIONS DIVISION FOR
SAMUEL COUNTY -- ON OUR HAND
CREW -- I'M A VERY -- I HAVE A
VERY PERSONAL STORY SHARE ON WHY
A FIREFIGHTERS NEED AB NINE
THIRTY TWO ON OCTOBER FIRST. TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN I WENT WITH
SOME FRIENDS -- AND OTHER
FIREFIGHTERS -- FROM MY STATION
AND FROM MY AREA TO THE ROUTE
NINETY ONE HARVEST FESTIVAL IN
LAS VEGAS -- IT WAS SUPPOSED TO
BE A RELAXING NIGHT OF GOOD
MUSIC -- IT WAS ACTUALLY THE
LAST DAY OF THE OF THE CONCERT
WE ARE GETTING READY TO GO HOME --
AND IT TURNED INTO A NIGHTMARE --
MY COLLEAGUE DAVID ARNOLD WHO
WORKS WITH ME AND I WERE ABOUT
TWENTY FIVE FEET FROM STAGE
RIGHT.
WHEN WE HEARD A LOUD POPPING
NOISE -- WE THOUGHT IT WAS
FIRECRACKERS UNTIL -- SOME DAR
LIQUID SPLATTERED ON DAVID
ARNOLD SPACE.
AND EVERYONE STARTED RUNNING --
LITTLE DID WE KNOW WHEN DAY WHEN
TO GO WHITE THE LIQUID FROM HIS
FACE HE NOTICED IT WASN'T A
DRINK BUT IT WAS PROBABLY JUST
SOME BLOOD -- YET AT THAT TIME
WE KNEW NOTHING WAS WRONG BUT WE
WEREN'T CLEAR YET ON WHAT WAS
GOING ON THEN WE SAW SOMEONE
LYING ON THE FLOOR.
AHEAD OF US AND A GENTLEMAN WAS
HOLDING INDIVIDUALS NECK -- WE
WENT OVER TO GO RENDER AID AND I
ASKED THE INDIVIDUAL THAT WAS
HOLDING PRESSURE ON THE
PATIENT'S NECK WHAT WAS WRONG HE
SAID HE HAD BEEN SHOT.
AND THAT'S WHEN WE KIND OF PUT
EVERYTHING TOGETHER AND NOTICED
THAT IT WAS AN ACTIVE SHOOTER --
WE RAN OVER AND RENDERED AID I
STE I STARTED DOING CPR -- AND
DAVE CHECKED -- FOR OTHER
SECONDARY INJURIES AND WOUNDS --
AND DURING ALL THAT TIME.
A HAIL OF GUNFIRE RAIN DOWN UPON
US FROM ABOVE -- EVERY TIME THAT
HAPPENED WE WOULD STOP CPR AND
STOP GIVING AID AND WE WOULD --
COVER PATIENT TRY TO MAKE
OURSELVES AS SMALL AS POSSIBLE
WHILE -- OTHER CONCERT GOERS
WERE KINDA TRAMPLING AROUND US
AND ON TOP OF US -- WE JUST KEPT
COVERING THAT INDIVIDUAL WAITING
FOR THE SHOOTING TO PASS -- AND
THEN WE CONTINUE -- TO TO
ADMINISTER CPR WHEN THE SHOOTING
STOPPED BRIEFLY -- WE SAW THAT
MOST EVERYONE HAD ESCAPED --
ESCAPE THE AREA.
THE STAGE LIGHTS WERE SHINING ON
US -- WHICH WERE WHICH WAS
LIGHTING ARE SCAPE ROUTE BUT
THEY ALSO MADE US -- KIND OF
LIKE A PERFECT TARGET I GUESS
YOU WOULD SAY.
THE NEXT ROUND A RAPID FIRE WAS
AIMED IN OUR GENERAL DIRECTIONS --
BULLETS WERE HITTING THE GROUND
ALL AROUND AND WE KEPT
ADMINISTERING CPR -- MIND YOU
WHEN THE BULLETS WERE FLYING IN
OUR GENERAL AREA OR IN OUR
DIRECTION THAT WE COULD FEEL --
WE WOULD COVER THE PATIENT TRY
TO MAKE OR SELL THE SMALLEST
POSSIBLE GIVE HIM A FIGHTING
CHANCE.
AND GIVE US A FIGHTING CHANCE
ALSO -- AROUND THE FIFTH FIFTH
OR SIX OF ALL YOUR MAG CHANGE --
A RAPID FIRE.
WE ARE ALL TALKING AMONGST
OURSELVES AND WE'RE GETTING
READY TO MOVE THE PATIENT
BECAUSE WE KNEW THAT THIS WAS
OBVIOUSLY AN ACTIVE SHOOTER
EVENT.
KNOWN WAS COMING TO OUR AID AND
WE'RE TRYING TO GET THIS
INDIVIDUAL IS THE BEST CHANCE WE
AND WHILE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
THAT MOVING THE PATIENT THAT'S
WHEN -- I SAID OKAY LET'S FINISH
MY LAST ROUND CPR AND THAT'S
WHEN I WAS STRUCK IN THE RIGHT
ARM THE RIGHT FORM -- THERE WAS
NOTHING MORE WE COULD DO FOR THE
VICTIM BUT WE KNEW IF WE STAYED
THERE WE'RE GOING TO DIE -- WE
RAN FOR OUR LIVES -- THE BULLETS
WERE.
WE COULD HEAR AND FEEL THEY WERE
GETTING CLOSER.
IT FELT IT FELT AS THOUGH THE
GUNMEN HAD -- KIND OF SINGLE
THIS OUT WHILE WE WERE.
MAKING -- MAKING A RUN FOR TO
TRY TO GET OUT OF THE ARENA AND
THE AREA -- THE REST OF WHAT
HAPPENED IS A BIT HAZY BUT I
REMEMBER WE GOT INTO A CAR AND
THEY DROVE ME TO THE CLOSEST
HOSPITAL -- AT THAT TIME I WAS
LOSING A LOT OF BLOOD I ENDED UP.
MY MY ASSOCIATE DAVID ARNOLD AND
I WE ENDED UP FINDING A
HANDKERCHIEF ON THE GROUND I
APPLIED A TOURNIQUET BUT STILL
FROM HOW FAR WE RAN FROM WHEN WE
GOT OUT OF THE CONCERT WHERE I
ACTUALLY GOT INTO A VEHICLE I
DON'T REALLY REMEMBER KIND OF
LIKE THE FOG.
OF WHAT HAPPENED -- IN THE EARLY
STAGES A SHOCK.
I EVENTUALLY SPENT SIX DAYS IN
THE HOSPITAL AND LOST ABOUT A
LEADER OF BLOOD FROM WHAT THEY
FROM AT THE HOSPITAL STAFF TELLS
ME -- NEXT TO BEING SHOT I WOULD
GUESS TO SAY THAT -- THAT
WORKERS COMPENSATION.
OR WORKERS COMP PROCESS -- AND
JUST THE PAPERWORK IN GENERAL
HAS BEEN THE BIGGEST NIGHTMARE --
BUT I REMEMBER I TOOK AN OATH AS
A FIREFIGHTER TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC I WAS FOLLOWING THOSE
RESPONSIBILITIES WHEN I WAS OUT
OF THE STATE NOW TO THE COUNTY
THAT I SERVE AND DESPERATELY
TRYING TO SAVE THAT INDIVIDUAL'S
LIFE.
BUT AFTER ALL THE PAPERWORK --
THE WORD CAME BACK DENIED -- MY
PAPERWORK THAT IS -- THERE IS NO
SUCH THING AS AN OFF DUTY
FIREFIGHTER WE DO TAKE AN OATH
AND WE RECOGNIZE OUR BOUNDARIES
BUT WE ARE ALWAYS ON THE JOB --
WE WE ARE TRAINED FIRST
RESPONDERS -- AND HAVE A DUTY
THAT A PUBLIC NO MATTER WHAT THE
EMERGENCY OR WHATEVER ARISES --
IT'S TRUE THAT MANY CALIFORNIA
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS WHO DID
THEIR DUTY THAT NIGHT -- BOTH
ACTIVE RETIRED MILITARY
EVERYTHING -- IT'S TRUE FOR
MYSELF THAT MANY OTHER
CALIFORNIA FIREFIGHTERS WHO
RENDERED AID -- WHEN THE WORST
HAPPENED IF EVER THERE WAS A JOB
RELATED INJURY IT WAS THIS EVEN
THOUGH IT DIDN'T HAPPEN IN
CALIFORNIA -- WE ARE SWORN TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC.
AND I HOPE THAT LEGISLATORS
YOU'LL PROTECT US AND PASSED THE
ASSEMBLY BILL NINE THIRTY TWO
THANK YOU AND GOD BLESS.
THANK YOU WOULD YOU LIKE TO ADD
ANYTHING MISS BURMA.
OKAY AS FOR A VOTE [inaudible]
ARE THERE.
SINCE HER WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
AND THEN -- AND THE MISTER
GIBSON WILL HAVE A QUESTION A
SOON HERE GO AHEAD.
YOU'RE RIGHT.
BY CHAIR SO SO CA SHANNON
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR.
OTHER FOLKS TO SPEAK IN FAVOR.
ARE THERE PERSONS SPEAKING
AGAINST THIS BILL WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK AGAINST IT [inaudible]
WELL.
YEAH PLEASE GO AHEAD THANK YOU
MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
FATE CALMLY WITH THE LA COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS.
WERE WE RESPECTFULLY HAVING
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
ON THIS BILL RIGHT NOW -- FOR
ONE REASON LAST YEAR WE JOINED A
COALITION OF LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
AND PUBLIC EMPLOYERS TO
COLLABORATE ON THE CHAIRS AB
SEVENTEEN FORTY NINE WHICH
PROVIDED A WORKERS COMPENSATION
BENEFITS FOR CERTAIN ACTS THAT
OCCUR OUTSIDE OF CALIFORNIA. FOR
CERTAIN CLASSIFICATIONS OF PEACE
OFFICERS.
THAT COLLABORATION.
WITH THE AUTHOR AND THE SPONSORS
OF SEVENTEEN FORTY NINE RESULTED
IN LEGISLATION THAT ALLOWED
LOCAL AGENCIES TO PROVIDE THESE
BENEFITS TO PEACE OFFICERS WHO
ARE IN STE INJURED OUTSIDE OF
CALIFORNIA.
BUT THE AMENDMENTS ALSO PLACE
NECESSARY PROTECTIONS FOR THE
EMPLOYER IN PLACE THAT STRUCK A
BALANCE BETWEEN ENSURING THOSE
OFFICERS ENGAGING IN CERTAIN
ACTS OUTSIDE THE STATE COULD
STATUTORILY BE COVERED BY
WORKERS COMP.
BUT ALSO PROTECTED EMPLOYERS
FROM CIVIL LIABILITY AND THE I'M
UNPREDICTABLE EXPOSURE ARE
CREATED BY THE ORIGINAL VERSION
OF AB.
SEVENTEEN FORTY NINE AB NINE
THIRTY TO CREATE THE DISPARITY
BETWEEN PEACE OFFICERS AND
FIREFIGHTERS 2% OUT OF STATE
INJURY CLAIMS TO THEIR EMPLOYERS.
THERE'S A NEED TO HAVE CLARITY
IN LA BETWEEN THESE TWO
CLASSIFICATIONS OF EMPLOYEES SO
WE WOULD LOVE TO WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR ON MOVING TOWARD
CLARIFYING THAT -- WHEN THIS
BILL MOVES TO THE PROCESS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GO AHEAD SIR THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS AT MY NAME'S JASON
SMELTER I'M HERE TODAY ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA COALITION ON
WORKERS COMPENSATION AND SEE SEC
ACCESS INSURANCE AUTHORITY.
FIRST OF ALL IT'S ONE OF
KNOWLEDGE ALONG WITH EVERYBODY
ELSE THE BRAVERY OF NOT ONLY
THIS FIREFIGHTER AND THE PEACE
OFFICERS BUT EVERYBODY THAT WAS
THERE THAT RENDER DATE -- WE
CERTAINLY ACKNOWLEDGE THAT --
LISTEN WE'RE IN AGREEMENT WITH
FAITH AND THE ONLY FOR THE LA
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS --
QUICKLY WHY WHAT ARE THE WHAT
ARE THE CONCERNS WE HAVE ON A
POLICY BASIS ABOUT HOW THIS IS
DONE SUPPOSED WHETHER IT'S DONE
FIRST.
WE'RE WORRIED ABOUT
INVESTIGATIVE DIFFICULTIES HOW
DO WE DETERMINE WHAT ACTIVITIES
ARE ACTUALLY BEING ENGAGED AND
AT THE TIME -- THESE INCIDENTS
CAN BE VERY HAZY SO WE'RE A
LITTLE BIT WORRIED ABOUT
COMPILING A FACT PATTERN THAT
WHEN WE DO INVESTIGATIONS ON
CLAIMS. TO AS YOU MENTIONED WERE
WORRIED ABOUT POTENTIAL CIVIL
LIABILITY.
AT THIRD IS SCOPE AND I THINK
THIS IS REALLY THE BIGGEST ONE
IF LIKE IF I COULD FOCUS THERE
FOR A SECOND.
I THINK WHAT YOU HEARD EARLIER
IS A VERY CLEAR DESCRIPTION --
OF A CIRCUMSTANCE UNDER WHICH WE
WOULD WANT TO PROVIDE THIS
COVERAGE OUTSIDE THE STATE WE
ALSO HAVE TO LOOK AT THE
LANGUAGE IN THE BILL -- AND
THINK OF ALL THE OTHER WAYS IN
WHICH IT COULD BE APPLIED -- SO
NO WE NEED TO SEPARATE OURSELVES
FROM THIS PARTICULAR SITUATION
AND LOOK AT KIND OF THE DAILY
TYPES OF CLAIMS THAT WE RECEIVE --
AS PUBLIC EMPLOYERS AND SO WE DO
HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT THE WAY THAT
THE BILL AS DRAFTED BECAUSE IT
IT ITS SCOPE IS FAR BEYOND THE
SPECIFIC SITUATION -- DISCUSSED
HERE -- AGAIN MUCH LIKE -- THE
LA COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
WE DO WANT TO WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR AND GET TO A PLACE JUST
LIKE WE DID ON SEVENTEEN FORTY
NINE I WERE WE CAN SUPPORT THE
BILL -- AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
DOING THAT SO THANK YOU.
JUST FOR THE RECORD -- WE ARE
NOT RECOMMENDING AMENDMENTS
TODAY TO THE BILL -- BUT IT IS
NICE THAT THE AUTHOR IS -- IS
OPEN TO FURTHER DISCUSSIONS WITH
THE TO ADDRESS SOME OF THESE
CONCERNS BUT THERE'S NO
RECOMMENDATION TO AMEND IT TODAY --
ANY OTHER FOLKS WISHING TO SPEAK
AGAINST THE BILL.
JOSH DUGGAR REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES AND OUR COLLEAGUES AT
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
JOINT POWERS AUTHORITIES -- BOTH
ALSO OPPOSED UNLESS AMENDED FOR
THE REASONS STATED THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MARKETS THAT
WHETHER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
SPECIAL DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO ALIGN OUR
COMMENTS WITH OUR COLLEAGUES
FROM BEFORE WE ARE ALSO OPPOSE
MUST AMENDED TO THE BILL THANK
YOU.
ANY OTHER PERSONS WISHING TO
SPEAK AGAINST THE BILL.
IF NOT OF A COUPLE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS SAID QUESTIONS MISTER
GIBSON HAD A COMMENT OR QUESTION
AND AND BERMAN HAS ONE AND THEN
MISTER COOPER HAS.
ONE GO AHEAD MIKE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER WE DIGEST IF I'M NOT
MISTAKEN WE DID A BILL LIKE THIS
LAST YEAR FOR POLICE OFFICERS
CORRECT CORRECT.
CORRECT -- AND LET ME IS SIMPLY
SAYS A FORMER POLICE OFFICER AND
MISSED COOLEY I'M SUSAN MISTER
COOPER'S HERE AND OTHERS -- WHEN
WE WERE FIRST WHEN I FIRST TOOK
A OF NO ONE TOLD ME THAT I WAS
ALWAYS TOLD I'LL BE POLICE
OFFICER SEVEN DAYS A WEEK?
YOU KNOW WITHOUT STOP IF WE
EMERGENCY OR SITUATION WENT DOWN
WE RESPOND -- I HAVE PERSONAL
FRIENDS WHO ARE FIREFIGHTERS MY
NEIGHBOR.
BEHIND ME IS A FIRE CAPTAIN --
SAME EXACT THING THE FIRE
ACADEMY -- ONCE YOU WENT THROUGH
THE CAT A ME YOU WERE A
FIREFIGHTER RESPONDING TO
EMERGENCIES -- YOU KNOW WHEN
THEY HAPPEN MY SISTER -- A NURSE
PRACTITIONER -- SAME EXACT THING
HOW CAN YOU SEPARATE AND SAY
THAT YOU DON'T WANT TO WORK
SHOULD NOT PUT YOURSELF TO
RENDER AID WHEN AID IS CALLED
UPON.
IN THE SITUATION OF LOS VEGAS.
PEOPLE RESPONDED ACCORDINGLY --
BUT TO COME BACK HOME AND BE
DENIED COMPENSATION -- FOR THIS
KIND OF A HOT ACT OF HORROR
ISN'T -- I THINK IT'S IT'S IT'S
IT'S DESPICABLE IS REALLY
DESPICABLE TO THE POINT WHERE WE
CAN'T TAKE CARE OF OUR OWN GOES
FIRST RESPONDERS RESPONDING TO
THOSE KINDS OF EMERGENCIES --
AND I THOUGHT WE JUST DID THIS
OF POLICE OFFICERS AND I WOULD
JUST OFFER -- THIS TO THE AUTHOR
OF THE BILL THAT LIKE TO BE
CONSIDERS CO AUTHOR OF THE BILL
I THINK YOU MOVE IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION WE SHOULD DO THIS.
AND WE SHOULD DO IT NOW.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
GIBSON -- MISTER COOPER BUT AS A
QUESTION OR COMMENT.
JUST A COMMENT THIS IS OBVIOUSLY
AN EXTRAORDINARY VINCE I WANNA
THINK THE OFFICE BRING THIS
FORWARD.
IN A FIREFIGHTER FOR HIS BRAVE
ACTIONS IT REALLY THE ONUS IS ON
THE EMPLOYEE THE BURDENS ON THE
EMPLOYEE TO SHOW THE INJURIES
GREW OF ACTIVITIES.
THEIR JOB OR DO YOU RELATED.
AND OTHER ENGAGING IN RESCUE
PROTECTIVE ACTIONS SO WE KNOW
THE WORKERS COMP PROCESS IS A
VERY ONEROUS PROCESS.
SO THERE TO ME YOUR CHECKS AND
BALANCES IN PLACE TO BE HONEST
THE UNIVERSE FOR THIS IS IS NOT
BIG UNIVERSE.
IN FUTURE INSTANCE LIKE THIS I
MEAN THEY DON'T COME ACROSS
EVERY DAY.
SELECT THINK -- FOR THE SOME
CONCERNS -- THAT WERE --
PRESENTED BY THE OPPOSITION --
ASSEMBLY FIND A GREAT DEAL
SUBSTANCE IN THAT SIDE
SUPPORTIVE.
OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU MISTER BERMAN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND I
JUST WANT TO THANK MR COURTS I'M
ALWAYS GOING TO SUPPORT THE BILL --
AND TWENTY FOUR HOURS BEFORE SO
THE THAT I I'M SURE YOU DON'T
RECALL BUT THE THE ARTISTS THAT
WAS ON STAGE WHEN THE SHOOTING
BROKE OUT WAS JASON ALDEAN
CORRECT -- IN TWENTY FOUR HOURS
BEFORE THAT I WAS WITH MY FIANCE
IMAGES NOW THE IN CONCERT IN
MOUNTAIN VIEW IN MY DISTRICT
SING AND DANCE ALONG AND HAVE AN
AWESOME TIME.
AND I CAN'T IMAGINE -- GOING
FROM SINGING ALONG THE NIGHT
TRAIN OR ONE OF HIS OTHER SONGS
AND THEN IMMEDIATELY SPRING INTO
ACTION -- AND KEEPING YOURSELF
IN DANGER AS YOU TRY TO RENDER
AID TO SOMEBODY WHO'S WHO'S BEEN
SHOT RATHER THAN RUNNING.
OUT LIKE EVERYBODY ELSE SO -- I
JUST WANT TO SAY THANK YOU --
FOR YOUR ACTIONS THAT NIGHT I'M
SORRY THAT THE SYSTEM FAILED YOU
WHEN YOU GOT BACK TO CALIFORNIA --
BUT LET'S REMEDY THAT SITUATION
AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER BERMAN
[inaudible]
MR BIGELOW.
FIRST OF ALL I'D LIKE TO SAY
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMITMENT
SERVICE AND EVERYTHING THAT YOU
DO AND WHAT WHAT YOU STAND.
AND REPRESENT HERE'S SOMEBODY
WHO WENT ABOVE AND BEYOND THE
CALL OF DUTY TO RENDER AID TO
SOMEONE ELSE -- TO THE TO THE
AUTHOR -- RECOGNIZING -- WHAT
THIS BILL DOES I WANNA?
FIND OUT IF YOUR IT'S YOUR
UNDERSTANDING THIS WOULD APPLY.
TO RESERVE DEPUTIES AND HEY CALL
FIREFIGHTERS.
OFTENTIMES USE OF THE FIRST
RESPONDERS WILL BE ON THE
FRONTLINE WHO SOMETIMES ARE
FULLY RECOGNIZED.
BUT THEY ARE CALLED TO DUTY AT
THE VERY MOMENT.
A FULL TIME PERSON IS CALLED TO
DUTY WHEN THOSE MOMENTS HAPPEN I
BEING ONE OF THOSE --
INDIVIDUALS OF FORTY SEVEN YEARS
AND BEEN CALLED MANY TIMES AND
EVEN TO THIS DAY.
IF YOU ARE MY PICK UP YOU'LL
FIND MY GEAR IT'S READY TO SERVE
TWENTY FOUR HOURS A DAY SEVEN
DAYS A WEEK.
AND THERE ARE MANY OTHER
INDIVIDUALS LIKE MYSELF BOTH
MALE AND FEMALE WHO GIVE THEIR
LIVES SOMETIMES ON THAT FRONT
LINE.
AND BEING SOMEONE WHO JUST
FINISHED TAKING THE NATIONAL
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT SYSTEMS.
MANAGEMENT -- COURSES AND
TESTING TO BECOME NATIONALLY
RECOGNIZED AND CERTIFIED FOR
NATIONAL EVENT WHICH WE'RE
SEEING MORE AND MORE OF THESE --
I THINK FOLKS LIKE THAT SHOULD
BE INCLUDED.
BECAUSE WHEN THAT CRISIS LIKE
WE'VE SEEN IN THIS STATE OCCURS.
IT'S GOING TO BE THOSE PEOPLE
WHO ARE RIGHT IN THOSE
COMMUNITIES THEY'RE GOING TO BE
CALLED.
WHETHER IT BE A MAJOR
CATASTROPHIC EVENT OF A FIRE
WHERE THERE'S A CATASTROPHIC
EVENT OF A A DERANGED INDIVIDUAL
WHO'S FIRING AIMLESSLY FOR NOTE.
PURPOSE OTHER THAN TO HARM.
SO I WOULD HOPE THAT THE SAME
PEOPLE WOULD BE INCLUDED AND IF
YOU WOULD BE SO.
INCLINED TO MAKE SURE THAT THOSE
FOLKS ARE INCLUDED I WOULD BE
HAPPY TO BE A CO AUTHOR AND HELP
YOU WITH THIS.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
BY COMMITTEE MEMBERS MISTER
COOLEY.
HELLO I THINK FOR BRING THIS
BILL FOR IT AND AS I JUST
THINKING ABOUT IT. ONE OF THE
ONE OF THE PLEASURES AS IT WERE
OF BEING A LAWYER.
IS IT FROM TIME TO TIME YOUR
LINES IN THE LAW.
THAT ARE BIGGER THAN THE CASE IN
WHICH THEY ARE UTTERED.
AND ABOUT A CENTURY AGO THERE
WAS A FAMOUS SUPREME COURT
DECISION WRITTEN BY OLIVER
WENDELL HOLMES. NINETEEN TWENTY
ONE BROWN VERSUS US IN WHICH HE
STATED.
DETACHED REFLECTION.
IS NOT REQUIRED IN THE FACE OF
AN UP LIFTED KNIFE.
AND I THINK THAT CAPTURES THIS
MOMENT THAT THERE'S TIMES WHEN
THINGS ARISE.
THAT PEOPLE ARE GOING TO RESPOND.
TO AND RESPOND TO INSTINCTIVELY.
AND THAT'S THERE'S ALLOWANCE FOR
THAT.
AND I THINK THAT'S WHAT THIS
BILL IS ALL ABOUT I
WHOLEHEARTEDLY SUPPORT IT --
THANK YOU VERY MUCH BEAUTIFUL
BEAUTIFUL OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS MISTER FRAZIER THANK
YOU VERY MUCH -- MISTER LOW FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD.
I CONSIDER ONE LUCKY AUTHOR TO
BE ABLE TO DO THIS RIGHT FOR
THIS FOR THIS -- A GROUP OF
PEOPLE -- AS A FATHER WHO LOST A
CHILD [inaudible]
AND THERE WAS.
AN OFF DUTY HI WITHDRAWAL OF SIR.
WHO SAVE MY LITTLE GIRL?
HAD THERE BEEN A DETERRENT SHE
WOULDN'T BE ALIVE TODAY.
WHY WOULD WE CREATED CURRENT?
IN SAVING PEOPLE'S LIVES. FOR
ANY REASON AT ALL.
MEANS A FORMER EMPLOYER
[inaudible]
BE GLADLY.
EXCEPT ADDITIONAL PREMIUMS FOR
INDIVIDUALS WHO SHOW BRAVERY.
FOR THAT I ASKED TO BE ADDED HAS
COOPER.
AND LOOK FORWARD TO YOUR SUCCESS.
AND I CAN'T THANK YOU ENOUGH.
ALL RIGHT MISTER FRAZIER THANK
YOU ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS MR LOW WOULD YOU LIKE.
TO CLOSER [inaudible]
CLOSER YOUR TEMPTATION -- THANK
YOU VERY MUCH COMMITTEE MEMBERS --
AS MANY OF YOU HAVE SPOKEN
CERTAINLY UNDERSTANDING THE
IMPORTANCE OF THIS ISSUE AND THE
LEGISLATIVE INTENT -- CERTAINLY
WE WILL CONTINUE TO WORK THROUGH
THE COMMITTEE PROCESS AND
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS AND
IDENTIFYING SOME OF THE OTHER.
ISSUES THAT HAVE BEEN ADDRESSED
BY SOME OF THE OTHER INDIVIDUALS
IN OPPOSITION -- AND SIMULATE
JUST.
AS THIS WAS BROUGHT TO MY
ATTENTION THE APPLICATION THAT
WE HAVE TO MAKE A CORRECTION. TO
MEMBERS OF SOCIETY AND THOSE
THAT PUT THEIR LIVES AT RISK
EACH AND EVERY DAY THIS IS ONE
CONTINUED ACTION THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR SHARING YOUR PERSONAL
TESTIMONY.
AND DAY OF VERY MUCH WOULD
WELCOME YOUR PARTNERSHIP IN
DOING THIS TOGETHER COLLECTIVELY
AS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WITH
RESPECT ASK PRIVATE.
ALL RIGHT TO THE THANK YOU FOR
ALL THE COMMENTS AND BACKGROUND
INFORMATION IN.
AND SIR TO YOU WHO.
HAD THAT.
A HORRIBLE FIRSTHAND EXPERIENCE
THANK YOU FOR A COMMON
SACRAMENTO AND SHARING YOUR
STORY AND WE HOPE WE CAN RECTIFY.
THIS SIR GOING FORWARD.
RECTIFY THE LAW THAT IS.
THERE'S A MOTION AND SECOND TO
LET'S VOTE.
ON EIGHTY NINE THIRTY TWO THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS DALY BY FAILING
AYE MAYES AYE MAYES AYE BERMAN.
BERMAN AYE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE WALDRON HI WALDRON
AYE CHAN.
CHAN I CHU.
CHU AYE COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE COOPER.
COOPER I FRAZIER.
FRAZIER I GIPSON.
OR GIPSON AYE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE KAMLAGER-DOVE HI
FOUND KAMLAGER-DOVE I VOEPEL.
THIRTEEN TWO ZERO THANK YOU
MISTER LOWE BILLS OUT.
THANK YOU THEY GIVE.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WITH TWO
REMAINING BILLS OF BOTH ARE MY
BILLS -- I SEE OUR INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER MISTER LARA HAS
ARRIVED.
WE'RE GONNA DO.
NOT A DIFFERENCE.
THAT A DIFFERENCE MR LARA WILL
DO AB SIXTEEN SEVENTY NINE FIRST
THAT IS A DEPARTMENT SPONSORED
BILL AND THEN WE'LL DO A. B.
NINE EIGHTY ONE THE PRIVACY BILL.
AND I'M I'M TURNING IT OVER TO
OUR VICE CHAIR MISTER MAYES
[inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
THANK [inaudible]
DOESN'T [inaudible]
THE BILL.
THE FACT IN WHICH WHOSE DAILY.
I THANK YOU YOU SEE HOW WE ROLL.
IT'S A GREAT COMMITTEE.
UNFORTUNATELY.
THIS -- AB SIXTEEN SEVENTY NINE
AS I SAID A SPONSORED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE.
IT ADDRESSES A FEE REVENUE FROM
INSURERS -- AND THE MONEY IS
THEN DISTRIBUTED TO LOCAL
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS TO PROSECUTE
FRAUD.
AUTOMOBILE INSURANCE FRAUD IS
ESTIMATED TO COST EVERY POLICY
HOLDER IN THE STATE BETWEEN TWO
AND THREE HUNDRED DOLLARS PER
YEAR -- EVERY YEAR PROSECUTORS
APPLY FOR MORE FUNDS THAT ARE
AVAILABLE FOR DISTRIBUTION IN
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT POINT.
THE AUTOMOBILE ANTI FRAUD
PROGRAM IS SUPPORTED BY TWO FEES
ONE FOR GENERAL ANTI FRAUD
EFFORTS IN THE OTHER TO
SPECIFICALLY TARGET ORGANIZED
CRIME EFFORTS.
THE FEES TO SUPPORT THESE
EFFORTS HAVE NOT BEEN CHANGED IN
TWENTY EIGHT YEARS OR TWENTY
YEARS RESPECTIVELY.
AGAIN WE'RE DEALING WITH TWO
DIFFERENT FEES.
THIS BILL SIMPLY RAISES THESE
FEES TO BETTER ENABLE THE
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE AND
LOCAL PROSECUTORS TO ENFORCE OUR
EXISTING ANTI FRAUD LAWS.
I THINK MR MR LARA IT MIGHT WITH
MY SCRIPT SAYS MICHAEL MARTINEZ
YOU'RE NOT MIKE MARTINEZ.
MISTER MISTER RICARDO LARA OF
THE ELECTED.
INSURANCE COMMISSIONER FOR THE
STATE IS HERE WITH ME TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE BEEN
WOULD YOU LIKE TO SAY A FEW
WORDS.
I'LL BE VERY QUICK THANK YOU
MEMBERS IT'S GREAT TO BE BACK IN
THE BUILDING.
THAT THIS -- THESE INCREASES
WILL PROVIDE ADDITIONAL TWENTY
FIVE MILLION ON TOP OF THE
EXISTING FUNDING -- IN PROGRAMS
TO IMPROVE PUBLIC SAFETY AND
ENSURE A GREATER PROTECTION FOR
CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS AS OUR
GREAT CHAIR NOTED OF THESE FEES
HAVE NOT BEEN RAISED.
IN TWENTY TO TWENTY EIGHT YEARS
RESPECTIVELY -- CALIFORNIA
CONTINUES TO BE GROUND ZERO FOR
INSURANCE FRAUD ON ALL FRONTS
AND SO WE WOULD GREATLY
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT TODAY ON
THE SUPPORT MEASURE FOR THE
DEPARTMENT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER LARA.
I DON'T KNOW IF THERE'S OTHER
FOLKS WHO WHAT YOU INTEND TO
SPEAK ON THIS WELL IT'S THAT'S
OPEN THIS UP TO YOU I HATE THIS
AT ALL.
THAT'S ALL THIS UP TO ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
I SEE SOMEONE COMING FOR HERE.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN DALY MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE A GOOD MORNING
MY NAME IS CHRISTINE GARCIA SAN
AND I'M A SUPERVISING DEPUTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY IN SANTA CLARA
COUNTY.
I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF A DISTRICT
ATTORNEY JEFF ROSEN I IN SUPPORT
OF ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN OR
SIXTEEN SEVENTY NINE AS A
CHAIRMAN DALY MENTIONED OF THE
COST OF INSURANCE FRAUD TO
CONSUMERS IN CALIFORNIA IS TWO
TO THREE HUNDRED DOLLARS.
PER CONSUMER IF YOU MULTIPLY
THAT BY THE NUMBER OF LICENSED
INSURED DRIVERS IN CALIFORNIA
THAT'S BETWEEN FOUR POINT SIX
AND SIX POINT NINE BILLION
DOLLARS WHICH COST CONSUMERS AS
A RESULT OF AUTO INSURANCE FRAUD.
A DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICES
ACROSS THE STATE WORK VERY
CLOSELY WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE TO CONDUCT TO
COLLABORATE ON OUT REACH AN
INVESTIGATION PROSECUTIONS OF
THESE AUTO FRAUD IN INSURANCE
CASES.
AND WE I KNOW AT LEAST ON BEHALF
OF OUR COUNTY -- WERE LIMITED BY
THE RESOURCES THAT WE HAVE FOR
EVERY INVESTIGATION THAT WERE
ABLE TO OPEN THEIR EIGHT TO TEN
INVESTIGATIONS THAT WE ARE NOT
ABLE TO ACT ON SO THESE
RESOURCES WOULD BE VERY MUCH
WELCOME BYE -- EVERYONE IS
INVOLVED IN THE FIGHT AGAINST
INSURANCE FRAUD AND FOR THOSE
REASONS I'D ASK YOU TO SUPPORT
THE LEGISLATION.
THANK YOU -- ANYMORE WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MIKE MATIC
CONSUMER WATCHDOG -- IN SUPPORT
OF THE MEASURE THANK YOU.
THAT'S GREAT WILL MOVE -- TO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE WILL COME BACK TO
QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS FOR
MEMBERS OR ANYBODY WHO HAS.
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS --
MISTER GOOD YOU WANT NOW.
BUT NOT THEN -- IT MR DAILY
WOULD YOU -- WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE.
THANK YOU FOR THIS SERVICE
SUPPORT OF COMMENTS AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
I JUST TAKE THE LIBERTY SINCE
OUR INSURANCE COMMISSIONERS HERE
IT'S GOOD TO SEE YOU I HAVE A
SENSE THAT THE LEGISLATURE IS
GOING TO HAVE.
A STRONGER RELATIONSHIP WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE NOW THAT
YOU WERE.
YOU WERE YOU WERE THERE -- BUT
IT IS GOOD TO SEE HERE IN THE
BUILDING -- WITH THAT.
A SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
YOU HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND.
ON A. B. SIXTEEN SEVENTY NINE DO
PASSED TO APPROACH.
DALY OUR DALY AYE MAYES FIVE
NAMES I BERMAN.
BERMAN AYE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW I CALDERON AYE CALDERON
AYE CHAN.
FAN I CHU.
CHU AYE COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE COOPER.
YEAH FRAZIER.
FRAZIER I GET SENT. TO GET SENT
I GRAYSON.
KAMLAGER-DOVE HI KAMLAGER-DOVE I
VOEPEL. ELEVEN TWO ZERO BILLS AT
ELEVEN ZERO STALEY ANOTHER BILL
GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH THE
LAST BILL IS -- A. B. NINE
EIGHTY ONE WHICH DEALS WITH
INSURANCE PRIVACY.
OF TO OUR VICE CHAIR AND MEMBERS
I WOULD LIKE TO ACCEPT THE
AMENDMENT SUGGESTED IN THE
ANALYSIS -- THERE IS A DETAILED
ANALYSIS THAT WE'VE ALL BEEN
GIVEN.
THE AMENDMENTS INCLUDE
PROVISIONS THAT HOLD THE
INSURANCE INDUSTRY ACCOUNTABLE
FOR DATA BREACHES.
UNDER THE CALIFORNIA CONSUMER
PRIVACY ACT.
WHICH ADDRESS THE USE OF MINORS
INFORMATION.
THE AMENDMENTS ALSO EXPRESS
INTENT TO HARMONIZE THE PRIVACY
RULES IN THE INSURANCE CODE WITH
THE RULES IN THE CALIFORNIA
CONSUMER PRIVACY ACT.
UNDER THE REGULATORY OVERSIGHT
AND ENFORCEMENT BY THE INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER.
ANOTHER AMENDMENT EXPRESSES
INTENT TO INCORPORATE INSURANCE
PRIVACY REGULATIONS ADOPTED BY
THE INSURANCE COMMISSIONER IN
THE INSURANCE CODE TO THE
FULLEST EXTENT POSSIBLE.
DOING SO I BELIEVE WILL MAKE THE
LAW MORE ACCESSIBLE TO CONSUMERS.
IT ADDS LEGISLATIVE FINDINGS AND
DECLARATIONS REGARDING THE
CENTRAL ROLE THE DATA COLLECTION
PLAYS AN INSURANCE RATE SETTING
UNDERWRITING IN CLAIMS HANDLING.
I INTRODUCED THIS BILL TO OPEN A
CONVERSATION BETWEEN THE
INSURANCE INDUSTRY AND PRIVACY
ADVOCATES TO FIND A WAY TO
CONTINUE.
THE DECADES LONG REGULATION OF
INSURANCE PRIVACY BY THE ELECTED
INSURANCE COMMISSIONER.
OUR INSURANCE PRIVACY LAWS ARE
SHOWING THEIR AGE AND PASSAGE OF
THE CALIFORNIA [inaudible]
CONSUMER.
PRIVACY ACT HAS PROMPTED US ALL
TO GIVE NEW CONSIDERATION HOW WE
GO ABOUT PROTECTING CONSUMER
PRIVACY.
I WANT TO THANK THE PRIVACY
ORGANIZATIONS THAT HAVE ENGAGED
WITH US ON THIS BILL AND ON
THESE ISSUES.
THE DISCUSSIONS HAVE BEEN
THOUGHTFUL AND CONSTRUCTIVE.
I'D LIKE TO MOVE THIS BILL
FORWARD TODAY TO ALLOW THOSE
DISCUSSIONS TO CONTINUE.
MISTER JOHN SURE RAKING IN FROM
THE ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
LIFE AND HEALTH INSURANCE
COMPANIES.
AND MR JEREMY MURS FROM THE
ASSOCIATION OF PROPERTY AND
CASUALTY INSURERS OF AMERICA.
ARE HERE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL.
I MOVES A BILL THAT.
THANK YOU CHEN MEMBERS JOHN
KERRY CAN ON BEHALF ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA LIFE AND HEALTH
INSURANCE COMPANIES.
MR DALY DID A GREAT JOB
SUMMARIZING THE BILL IN OUR
EFFORTS ALL KEEP MY COMMENTS
RELATIVELY SHORT THIS MORNING.
BREAD DO THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
NOTE THAT INSURES ATTACH STRONG
PRIVACY RULES ON THE BOOKS FOR
QUITE SOME TIME NOW.
AND OUR REGULATORY FRAMEWORK
UNDER COMMISSIONER LAUREN THE
DEPARTMENT SHARON'S FASTER OF
OUR POLICY HOLDERS AND CONSUMERS
WELL.
BUT WE ALSO RECOGNIZE THAT AS
TECHNOLOGY CONTINUES TO ADVANCE
IN CHANGED SO MUCH OUR BUSINESS
PRACTICES.
AND THAT'S WHY WE'RE WORKING
WITH CONSUMER PRIVACY GROUPS TO
UPDATE OUR PRIVACY LAWS.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUE THIS
CONVERSATIONS AND AS A MOVE THIS
BILL FOR TODAY SO WE CONTINUE TO
DO THAT JOB.
SELECT LAST RIVAL.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS YOUR
MEMBERS THE AMERICAN PROPERTY
CASUALTY INSURANCE ASSOCIATION.
ALSO WITHOUT A VOICE TODAY --
BUT WE ARE SUPPORTIVE OF AB --
NINE EIGHTY ONE I'LLKEEP IT
BRIEF WITH THE THE TO MOTIONS WE
WOULD -- ASSOCIATE -- OURSELVES
LARGER WITH THE CHAIRS COMMENTS --
IN WITH MR SHURIKENS COMMENTS --
WE THANK THE PRIVACY GROUPS THAT
ARE ENGAGED IN A CONVERSATION
ABOUT MODERNIZING THE AYE AYE
PPA WE THINK THEY'VE BEEN
PRODUCTIVE DISCUSSIONS -- THEY
WE LOOK FOR THOSE DISCUSSIONS
CONTINUING -- AS INSURERS WE'VE
LIVED UNDER THIS COMPREHENSIVE
STATUTORY SCHEME FOR THIRTY
YEARS -- SO UPDATING MAKES A LOT
OF SENSE AND WE ARE DR -- TODAY.
THANK YOU MOVE ON TO ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
OF HIM STONE STONE ADVOCACY ON
BEHALF OF ALL STATE INSURANCE IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
TERRY MCHALE WITH THEIR AND READ
NECESSITY IT'S IN BEHALF OF USA
A INSURANCE MILITARY COMPANY
FOUNDED BY THE MILITARY FOR THE
MILITARY.
OBVIOUSLY WE TAKE GREAT PRIDE IN
GUARANTEEING THE SECURITY OF OUR
INDIVIDUALS.
WHO ARE THE MOST SENSITIVE
POSITIONS IN GOVERNMENT AND
BUSINESS?
THANK YOU FOR THE AMENDMENTS WE
SUPPORT THIS BILL AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING.
WITH THE ASSEMBLYMAN IN THE
FUTURE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SEVEN TAYLOR WITH THE PERSONAL
INSURANCE FEDERATION A
CALIFORNIA HERE IN SUPPORT THANK
THE AUTHOR.
WHERE ACCURACY ON BEHALF OF
STATE FARM INSURANCE AND SUPPORT
THANK?
SHARE MISTER ICE CHAIR JOHN DORY
ON BEHALF OF MARK YOUR INSURANCE
IN SUPPORT APPRECIATE THE EFFORT
ON BOTH SIDES TO MOVES BEFORE.
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MARIN
HIGGINS ON BEHALF OF AMERICAN
INTERNATIONAL GROUP IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING SHERRY MCCUE
REPRESENT IN THE PACIFIC
ASSOCIATION DOMESTIC INSURANCE
COMPANIES AND THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION INSURANCE AND
FINANCIAL ADVISORS AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN FOR STACEY
DRAWING ON BEHALF OF NATIONWIDE
IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MY CONNECTION
ON BEHALF OF THE AUTOMOBILE CLUB
OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA HERE IN
SUPPORT.
THE TAURUS STORE WITH FARMERS
INSURANCE HERE IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS MIKE
FOLLOWED FOR THE CIVIL JUSTICE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA AND
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
HEALTH UNDERWRITERS IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS JOHN NORWOOD
NORWOOD ASSOCIATES -- HERE TO
SUPPORT ON BEHALF OF NUMEROUS OF
OUR INSURANCE CLIENTS THAT ARE
LISTED IN THE ANALYSIS THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
MEDICAL DRAMA SENTRY INSURANCE
IN SUPPORT.
GEN REMEMBERS POLL THAT FILLED
IN BEHALF TRAVELERS AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MELANIE CUEVAS
WORKING THàNH OFTEN HURT MAN ON
BEHALF OF INSURANCE SERVICES
OFFICE ALSO IN SUPPORT THANK
THANK YOU.
NAMELY THE DRUNK YOU CAPTAIN
ASSOCIATES ON BEHALF OF C. S. A.
INSURANCE GROUP IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT THEN WILL MOVE TO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
THANKS.
NICE WORK.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS MY NAME SAMANTHA CORBIN
AND I'M HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF
MY CLIENTS -- COMMON SENSE KIDS
ACTION A CO SPONSOR OF EIGHTY
THREE SEVENTY FIVE ACLU
CALIFORNIA THE ELECTRONIC
FRONTIER FOUNDATION AND PRIVACY
RIGHTS CLEARING HOUSE.
IN ADDITION I'M THE PRIMARY
COORDINATOR OF THE COALITION OF
MORE THAN A DOZEN PRIVACY
ORGANIZATIONS AROUND THE COUNTRY
COMMITTED BOTH TO PRESERVING AND
STRENGTHENING AB.
THREE SEVENTY FIVE THE
CALIFORNIA CONSUMER PRIVACY ACT
AT FIRST I WANT TO START BY
THINKING THE CHAIR.
HIS COMMITTEE AND THE PROPONENTS
OF THE MEASURE FOR WEEKS OF
DIALOGUE.
I WHICH IS BEEN ONGOING AND
THOUGHTFUL AND WELL WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING THOSE
CONVERSATIONS WE DO STILL HAVE
SOME CONCERNS ABOUT AB -- NINE
EIGHT ONE AND RESPECTFULLY DO
OPPOSE THE BILL AS WRITTEN --
PULLING CONSISTENTLY DEMONSTRATE
THAT A BIPARTISAN SUPERMAJORITY
OF CALIFORNIANS VALUE THEIR
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT TO PRIVACY
AND DESIRE STRONG STATUTORY
PROTECTIONS AS WELL AS THE RIGHT
TO ENSURE THE RIGHTS ARE
ENFORCED.
LAST YEAR THE PASSAGE OF THE CPA
WHICH ESTABLISHED IMPORTANT
RIGHTS FOR PEOPLE TO KNOW HOW
BUSINESSES FROM ANY INDUSTRY
COLLECT AND SELL PERSONAL
INFORMATION WAS AN IMPORTANT
STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION. TO
PROTECTING CONSUMERS AND MEETING
THIS DEMAND.
AS WRITTEN THIS BILL WOULD
SIGNIFICANTLY WEAKEN THE LAW AND
THE PROTECTIONS THAT
CALIFORNIANS WANT AND DESERVE IN
PART THIS IS DUE TO A LACK OF
THE MODERNIZATION IN THE I. P.
P. A. AS WELL AS THE FACT.
THAT MOST EXISTING INSURANCE
LAWS HAVE HURRY MERRILY BEEN
WRITTEN FROM THE CORPORATE
INSURANCE INDUSTRY PERSPECTIVE
RATHER THAN FROM THE PERSPECTIVE
OF THE CONSUMERS THAT THEY SEEK
TO SERVE.
TODAY AND IN THE INTEREST OF
TIME -- BRIEFLY COVER SOME OF
THE MORE CONCERNING ISSUES THAT
WE DO HAVE WITH THE CURRENT
VERSION OF NINE EIGHT ONE FIRST
THE DEFINITION OF PROTECTED
PERSONAL INFORMATION IN THE C.
C. P. A. IS FAR BROADER THAN
WHAT IS COVERED IN AYE PPA.
AS A RESULT IN AT A MINIMUM
CONSUMERS AND MUST BE EXPANDED
TO MATCH THE DEFINITIONS IN THE
CONSUMER PRIVACY ACT.
SECOND THE SCOPE OF THE I. P. P.
A.'S LIMITED TO INDIVIDUALS FOR
APPLICANTS OR WHO OTHERWISE
ALREADY HAVE A RELATIONSHIP
WHERE WITH THE INSURER WHERE IS
THE CCPA PROVIDES RIGHTS FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS REGARDLESS OF
WHETHER OR NOT THEY HAVE A
BUSINESS RELATIONSHIP.
WITH A PARTICULAR ENTITY.
THIRD THIS ECPA PROVIDES
CONSUMERS WITH RIGHTS TO
PORTABILITY AND DELETION
ESSENTIALLY THE IDEA THAT A
CONSUMER OWNS OUR INFORMATION
AND SHOULD BE ABLE TO RECEIVE A
COPY OF THAT INFORMATION AND
TRANSFERIT TO ANOTHER ENTITY IF
SO DESIRED.
AND FURTHER THAT A CONSUMER
SHOULD BE ABLE TO ASK THAT THE
ENTITY DELETE THAT INFORMATION
IT POSSESSES ABOUT THE CONSUMER.
THE LACK OF MODERNIZATION IN THE
AYE PPA ARGUABLY OUTDATED NATURE
OF THE INSURANCE INDUSTRY'S IN
PERSON AND ON PAPER BUSINESS
MODEL AND CONFUSING PROVISIONS
WHICH SEEMINGLY ALLOW INSURERS
TO DENY CONSUMERS REQUEST TO
RECEIVE OR DELETE THEIR OWN DATA
FOR ANY REASON AT ALL.
WE ALL NEED TO BE REVISED IN
ORDER TO MERE THE PROTECTIONS
AFFORDED THROUGH THE CCPA.
OUT FOURTH THERE'S AN ENORMOUS
DISCONNECT BETWEEN THE
REQUIREMENTS FOR NOTICE AND
DISCLOSURE OF PRIVACY RIGHTS IN
THE C. C. P. EIGHT AND THE I. PA.
SIGNIFICANT HARMONIZATION AND
MODERNIZATION HERE WE NEED TO
OCCUR TO ADEQUATELY INFORM
CONSUMERS ABOUT DATA PRACTICES
AND TO ATTAIN THEIR CONSENT IN
ORDER TO MATCH THE PROTECTIONS
AFFORDED. TO THEM THROUGH.
THREE SEVENTY FIVE FINALLY AND
WE DO APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR AND
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS --
REGARDING THE DATA BREACH
PROVISION -- BUT WE DO STILL
HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT ENFORCEMENT --
AND PARTICULARLY A CONSUMER'S
RIGHTS TO TAKE ACTION -- SHOULD
AN INSURER FAIL TO MEET THE
REQUIREMENTS OF THE LAW AND WE
DEFINITELY HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT.
THE RESOURCES IN THE INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER'S OFFICE AND IF
THEY ARE IN FACT ADEQUATE -- TO
ACT AS ESSENTIALLY THE
REGULATORY BODY ON PRIVACY
SPECIFICALLY.
IN THIS MANNER AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING CAN A
CONVERSATIONS WITH YOUR OFFER.
SKEWS ME WITH YOUR OFFICE THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
MEGAN SUPERS ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIANS WERE CONSUMER
PRIVACY AWARE AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL AS IS IN
PRINT TODAY -- WELL WE'RE
OPPOSED TO NINETY ONE WE DO
APPRECIATE THE ENGAGEMENT WITH
THE AUTHOR AND HIS COMMITTEE
STAFF IN THE OTHER STAKEHOLDERS.
CALIFORNIANS FOR CONSUMER
PRIVACY WITH A CO SPONSOR OF AB
THREE SEVENTY FIVE THE
CALIFORNIA CONSUMER PROTECTION
ACT LAST YEAR.
AT THE CALIFORNIA CONSUMER
PRIVACY ACT PROVIDED IMPORTANT
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS AND
MECHANISM FOR CALIFORNIANS TO
EXERCISE THEIR RIGHTS TO PRIVACY
PROVIDED.
UNDER THE CONSTITUTION OF THE CZ
P. A. ALLOWS CONSUMERS TO KNOW
ALL THE DATA BUSINESS COLLECT
ABOUT YOU DELETE DATA YOU'VE
BEEN.
YOU'VE GIVEN TO A BUSINESS HAVE
THE RIGHT TO SAY NO TO THE SALE
OF YOUR INFORMATION AND HOLD
COMPANIES ACCOUNTABLE IN THE X.
CENTER THEY KNEW NOT DO NOT TAKE
REASONABLE MEASURES TO PROTECT
YOUR DATA.
I AM EIGHTY NINE EIGHTY ONE
WOULD EXEMPT INSURANCE
INSTITUTIONS AGENTS AND THEIR
INSURANCE SUPPORT ORGANIZATIONS
FROM THE C. CPA.
THE CURRENT PRIVACY FRAMEWORK
FOR THE INSURANCE INDUSTRY DOES
NOT PROVIDE THE SAME LEVEL OF
PRIVACY PROTECTIONS.
THAT ACCOUNTS CALIFORNIA
CONSUMERS ARE PROVIDED UNDER THE
TCPA AND AS A BASELINE WE THINK
THAT WE'RE THAT THERE IS
OVERLAPPING LAW THE CCPA SHOULD
TAKE PRECEDENCE.
AS PREVIOUSLY NOTED THE TCPA
PROVIDE THE CONSUMER THE RIGHT
TO KNOW WHAT DATA A BUSINESS OF
COLLECTED ABOUT THE CONSUMER.
CURRENT INSURANCE LAW AND
REGULATION APPEAR TO PROVIDE A
MUCH MORE LIMITED SCOPE OF WHAT
A CONSUMER CAN REQUEST AND WHAT
AN INSURER MUST DISCLOSE THIS IS
JUST ONE OF SEVERAL EXAMPLES
WERE EXISTING INSURANCE LAW AND
REGULATION DOES NOT PROVIDE.
PRIVACY PROTECTIONS COMMENSURATE
WITH THE C. C. P. A AND FOR
THOSE REASONS WE MUST
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE.
AT THIS POINT AND LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUING CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE AUTHOR [inaudible]
GREAT.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS LIKE MATIC
REPRESENTING CONSUMER WATCHDOG --
MY WE WE ARE PROPOSED TO AB.
NINETY ONE BECAUSE EXEMPTS
INSURANCE INSTITUTIONS AGENTS
AND INSURANCE SUPPORT
ORGANIZATION I'M GONNA MAKE A
COUPLE OF QUICK POINTS AND
TRYING NOT TO BE REDUNDANT.
THE THE FIRST IS THE DEFINITION
OF SINCE INSURANCE SUPPORT
ORGANIZATION.
NOW SOME INSURANCE ABOARD
ORGANIZATIONS ARE ANY
INSTITUTION ENGAGING IN
FINANCIAL ACTIVITIES SET FORTH
IN THE U. S. CODE.
TITLE TWELVE AND THAT'S DOING
BUSINESS IN CALIFORNIA AND CENTS
PER OUR FINANCIAL COAT THAT'S
LANDING EXCHANGING.
TRANSFERRING CREDIT CARDS
INVESTING SAFEGUARDING MONEY OR
SECURITIES ISSUING -- INSURING
ISSUING ANNUITIES ACTING AS A
PRINCIPAL AGENT OR BROKER
PROVIDING FINANCIAL INVESTMENT
OR ECONOMIC ADVISORY SERVICES
AMONG ANY MANY OTHER THINGS THAT
ARE ARE SET FORTH IN THE
INVESTMENT COMPANY ACT OF
NINETEEN FORTY IN ESSENCE WHEN
YOUR PRIVATE INFORMATION IS
DISCLOSED OR DATE IS PACKED.
WHILE IN THE POSSESSION OF ANY
INSURANCE COMPANY.
AGENT OR FINANCIAL SERVICE AND
AT THE HERE WILL BE NO
PROTECTION FOR UNAUTHORIZED
DISCLOSURE THERE'S NO
PORTABILITY OF YOUR INFORMATION
AND THERE'S NO PRIVATE RIGHT OF
ACTION TO RECOVER DAMAGES.
THE ONLY PENALTIES AVAILABLE ARE
ADMINISTRATIVE.
AND THAT MEANS THAT THE
INSURANCE COMMISSIONER CAN FIND
A COMPANY YOU CAN SUSPEND THEIR
LICENSE.
AND HE CAN ALLOW AN ACTION FOR
EQUITY THAT MEANS IF I'M MY DATE
IS BRIDGE I GO TO EQUITY COURT.
AND EIGHT ASPIRIN JUNCTION I
MEAN SOMEONE SPEND A TON OF
MONEY JUST TO GET THEM TO NOT DO
SOMETHING OR TO DO SOMETHING I
WANT THEM TO DO.
THERE'S NO RECOVERY FOR DAMAGES.
NOW I WISH I WAS WRONG BUT IN
TWO THOUSAND THREE WHEN WE WROTE
THIS LAW IT WAS STATE OF THE ART
NOW NOT SO MUCH.
SO.
THE PROPONENTS OF NINE NINE
EIGHT ONE OF ARGUE THAT THE
ADMINISTRATIVE ACTIONS OF THE
INSURANCE COMMISSIONER ARE
SUFFICIENT FOR CONSUMERS.
OR THAT THE TCPA PREAMPS AND
PREVENTS THE INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER FROM IS ENFORCEMENT
AUTHORITY.
THE FACT IS THAT INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER CAN STILL DO
EVERYTHING HE ALREADY CAN'T DO.
NOTHING CHANGES ON THE
REGULATORY SIDE OF THE EQUATION.
THE ONLY DIFFERENCE IS THAT
CONSUMERS CAN TAKE ACTION TO
PROTECT THEIR OWN INFORMATION.
ALL COMPANIES HAVE TO TAKE
REASONABLE STEPS TO PROTECT
THEIR DATA.
AND IF THEIR INFORMATION IS
DISCLOSED WITHOUT AUTHORIZATION
AND THEY DID NOT TAKE REASONABLE
STEPS THE KEY WORDS TO PROTECT
THAT.
THEN THE CONSUMER HAS A PRIVATE
RIGHT OF ACTION TO RECOVER
DAMAGES.
IN CLOSING NINE EIGHT ONE MERELY
SHIELDS THE ENTIRE INSURANCE AND
FINANCIAL INDUSTRIES FROM ANY
REAL OR ENFORCEABLE DUTIES.
RESPONSIBILITIES OR INCENTIVES
TO PROTECT THE PERSONAL PRIVATE
INFORMATION OF CALIFORNIANS.
SO ALL OF OUR PERSONAL PRIVATE.
INFORMATION WILL REMAIN
VULNERABLE IN OUR FINANCIAL
DOCUMENTS AND TRANSACTIONS
WITHOUT THE REMEDIES PROVIDED IN
THE C. C. PA.
THANK YOU SO MUCH WE WOULD.
CONTINUE TO OPPOSE THIS MEASURE
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH
WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION BUT
PLEASE MAKE SURE THESE JUST
STATE YOUR AND YOUR NAME AN
ORGANIZATION AND YOUR POSITION.
TO BE AN ATTACK OR THE CONSUMER
ATTORNEYS OF CALIFORNIAN
OPPOSITION WE APPRECIATE THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS AND LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH -- THE
AUTHOR AND STAKEHOLDERS.
GREAT SEEING NO FURTHER
WITNESSES AND IN OPPOSITION I
WILL COME BACK TO THE A
COMMITTEE FOR ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS [inaudible]
MR COOLEY.
WELL I JUST WANT TO JUMP IN IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL -- AND I'LL
ACTUALLY MOVE THE BILL IT
STARTED TO MOVE AND WILL OKAY --
THE UNDERLYING LAWN THIS YEAR
HAS BEEN THERE FOR FORTY YEARS.
IT WAS ADOPTED IN.
NINETEEN NINETY I PROBABLY HAD A
HAND IN WRITING THE ANALYSES ON
THAT BILL DRAFTING THE BILL.
IT WAS BASED UPON ANY I SEE
MODEL.
SOURCES REGULATION WASN'T JUST A
CALIFORNIA IDEA WAS A NATIONAL
IDEA GROW THE NATIONAL
REGULATORY SYSTEM.
INSURANCE IS A SPECIALIZED JERRY
BECAUSE YOU CONDUCTED VISITORS
BASED UPON THE USE OF
INFORMATION THIS IS A PROCESS
KNOWN AS UNDERWRITING.
AN UNDERWRITING SOMETHING PLAYS
OUT OVER TIME BASED ON THE
THAT'S AVAILABLE AND PERMISSION
TO READ JUST.
I THINK FOR THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AS WELL TO KNOW WHY THIS
STATUTE THAT MISTER DALY'S BILL
OF PRESERVING PLACE SUPPLIES.
THIS REMARK SECTION SEVEN NINETY
ONE INSURANCE CO FROM NINETEEN
EIGHTY IT IS NOT BEEN MODIFIED
SINCE PASSED IN. NINETEEN EIGHTY
WHICH I THINK INDICATES THE
SUBTLE NATURE OF THIS LAW.
THE PURPOSE OF THIS ARTICLE IS
ESTABLISHED TENER FOR THE
COLLECTION USE AND DISCLOSURE OF
INFORMATION.
GATHERING CONNECTS WITH INTEREST
TRANSACTIONS BY INSURANCE
INSTITUTIONS AGENTS OR INSURANCE
SUPPORT ORGANIZATIONS. TO
MAINTAIN A BALANCE WHEN THE NEED
FOR INFORMATION BY THOSE
CONDUCTING THE BUSINESS
INSURANCE.
IN THE PUBLIC'S NEED FOR
FAIRNESS AND INSURANCE
INFORMATION PRACTICES.
INCLUDING THE NEED TO MINIMIZE
INTRUSIVE IS TO ESTABLISH A
REGULATORY MECHANISM. TO ENABLE
NATURAL PERSONS TO ASCERTAIN
WHAT INFORMATION BEING OR HAS
BEEN COLLECTED ABOUT THEM.
CONNECT WITH INSURANCE
TRANSACTIONS AND HAVE ACCESS TO
SUCH INFORMATION FOR THE PURPOSE
OF VERIFYING OR JUST PRUDENCE
ACCURACY. TO LIMIT THE
DISCLOSURE OF INFORMATION
COLLECTED IN CONNECTION WITH
INSURANCE TRANSACTIONS.
INTO ENABLE INTEREST APPLICANTS
AND POLICY HOLDERS TO OBTAIN THE
REASONS FOR ANY ADVERSE
UNDERWRITING DECISION.
WHY DO I FEEL WE HAVE A VERY
COMPLICATED FIELD OF ENTERPRISE?
THE SUBJECT TO AN INFORMATION
LAW THE GREW OUT OF A NATIONAL
REGULATORY FRAMEWORK.
BEEN THERE FOR FORTY YEARS I
WOULD NOT DISAGREE THAT THERE
MAY BE SOME WAY IN WHICH YOU
MIGHT IN TIME MAKE SOME
ADJUSTMENT.
BUT I WOULD POINT OUT THAT THE
LAST TIME THE LEGISLATURE
ADOPTED A PRIVATE RIGHT OF
ACTUAL DISTRICT INSURANCE
BUSINESS -- IT WAS IN.
NINETEEN NINETY NINE AND WAS
PROPER REPUDIATED BY THE VOTERS
OF CALIFORNIA BY MORE THAN.
TWO TO ONE I THINK INSTINCTIVELY
UNDERSTAND THAT. TO SET A
INSURANCE LITIGATION TARGET ON
INSURANCE BUSINESS.
CAN LEAD TO A GREAT DEAL
EXPENSIVE WILL TRANSLATE INTO
RATE.
AND COST INCREASES SO I THINK
IT'S ACTUALLY A VERY REASONABLE
NOTION.
THAT A LAW THAT COMES OUT OF THE
NATIONAL ANY I SEE REGULATORY
SYSTEM.
REPRESENTS A BALLOT IN MULTIPLE
INTEREST.
AND IS WELL SETTLE IN FORTY
YEARS BOTH WITH THAT SYSTEM BUT
UNDER SARBANES OXLEY HIS FEDERAL
DUTIES ON CORPORATIONS.
DODD FRANK IT'S FEDERAL DUES ON
CORPORATIONS.
IS WORTH MAINTAINING.
AND I FINALLY WANT TO NOTE THAT.
IN AS MUCH OF PROP ONE OH THREE
WHICH CONSUMER WATCHDOG WAS
INSTRUMENTAL IN THE ADOPTION OF
SPECIFIED SIXTEEN RATING FACTOR
FOR AUTO INSURANCE.TO START
HAVING A SYSTEM WHERE PEOPLE CAN
TAKE DATA OUT OF THE SYSTEM
WITHOUT EXPAND HOW YOU RECORD
RECONCILE THOSE PIECES.
IS ITSELF ALSO.
RECKLESS WE ARE UNDER PROP ONE
OH THREE THERE ARE THESE
SPECIFIED RATING FACTORS YOU
CANNOT HAVE OF THE RATING
FACTORS YOU CAN ONLY MAKE
DECISIONS.
BASED ON THOSE THINGS AND SO
THERE'S NO EXPLANATION OF HOW TO
IN A WAY WITH DATA.
RECONCILES WITH THAT INSURE
OBLIGATION UNDER VOTER PASSED
LAW FROM.
NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT SO I THINK
IT'S A VERY GOOD BILL I THINK
THE CHAIR FOR BRING IT FORWARD.
THANK YOU MISTER COOLEY FOR THAT
HISTORY LESSON -- WE'RE GONNA
MOVE -- TO MISTER CALDERON AND
THEN DID.
DID -- MISS KAMLAGER-DOVE ALSO
OKAY WILL GO TO CALLED ON FIRST
IF THAT'S OKAY AND THEN --
KAMLAGER-DOVE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR --
APPRECIATE YOUR WORK ON THIS
ISSUE -- YOU KNOW.
OBVIOUSLY WHEN WE DID THE CCPA
WAS UNDER CERTAIN CIRCUMSTANCES
WHEN WE COULDN'T TAKE A LOT OF
CERTAIN THINGS INTO
CONSIDERATION WAS.
WAS MORE OF A AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
US TO HUSTLE TO AVOID WHAT WAS
CERTAINLY GOING TO BE A DISASTER
ON THE BALLOT -- GIVEN WHAT THE
LAW -- THAT WAS PROPOSED IN HOW
WAS GOING TO BE PASSED AND HOW
WOULD HAVE APPLIED CALIFORNIA
BUSINESSES AND WHAT THAT WOULD
HAVE MEANT GOING FORWARD -- FOR
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
OBVIOUSLY WE'RE VERY PROUD OF
WHAT THE CZ PA HAS ACCOMPLISHED
AND WE WANT TO CONTINUE TO
OPERATE.
IN A WAY THAT IS TRUE -- TO
PEOPLE WANTING MORE CONTROL MORE
POWER OVER THEIR PERSONAL
INFORMATION THE AYE AYE PA AYE
AYE PPA.
HAS BEEN AROUND FOR THIRTY YEARS --
AND HAS BEEN DOING AN ADEQUATE
JOB BUT IT BUT I THINK WHAT HAS
BEEN RECOGNIZED -- BY -- THIS
COMMITTEE BY YOU AS WELL AS THE
PROPONENTS AND I THINK SOME OF
THE YEP.
OPPONENTS.
IS THIS NEED TO UPDATE IT AND
AND I THINK THAT -- THE
OPPORTUNITY THAT IS EXISTING
RIGHT NOW WITH YOU AN OFFERING
THIS BILL IS TO UPDATE THE AYE
AYE PPA I'M NOT SO THAT.
ALL INSURANCE COMPANY SHOULD BE
SUBJECT TO THE PROVISIONS OF THE
CZ PA WHICH REALLY WHEN YOU WHEN
YOU THINK ABOUT IT WAS MEANT FOR
A LOT OF TECH COMPANIES AND AND
HOW THEY THEY USE AND SELL AND
AND Là HOW TO USE.
PERSONAL INFORMATION OF
INDIVIDUAL CELL.
WHAT I WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU?
WHICH IS ALREADY WHAT YOU'RE
DOING BUT WHAT I WOULD CONTINUE
TO ENCOURAGE ESPECIALLY IF THIS
BILL INTO MAKING IT TO THE FLOOR --
IS THAT YOU -- CONTINUE TO BE
OPEN TO PROVISIONS WITHIN THE CC
PA -- AND UPDATING THE I. P. P.
A. AND THAT THE PROPONENTS OF
THIS BILL OF OF OF THIS BILL IN
THE INSURANCE COMPANIES ARE OPEN
TO PROVISIONS THAT ARE IN THE C.
C. PA. TO BE IMPLEMENTED IN THE
AYE PPA -- BECAUSE IT IS
IMPORTANT WE NEED TO MODERNIZE
ALWAYS NEED TO CONTINUE TO TO TO
MODERNIZE OUR REGULATORY
FRAMEWORK SO THAT IT IS.
RELEVANT IN TODAY'S DAY AND TIME
I THINK THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY
TO DO THAT AND SO FOR THAT I'M
ALWAYS HAPPY SECOND A BILL AND I
WILL BE VOTING YES.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER MISS
KAMAGRA OF HEY I JUST HAD A
QUESTION -- THAT YOU COULD --
JUST -- EXPAND ON DOES THIS BILL
UNRAVELED PRIVACY PROTECTIONS
IT'S CERTAINLY NOT THE INTENT.
TO MISS COM LONGER OF IN THE
BIGGER PICTURE -- AS MR COOLEY
EXPLAINED -- THE INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER WHO WAS ELECTED AS
HAD.
A SUBSTANTIAL REGULATORY
AUTHORITY SINCE.
NINETEEN EIGHTY NOW THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL OF OUR STATE IS ALSO
ELECTED WILL HAVE REGULATORY
AUTHORITY ON THE ENTIRE MASS OF
THE CALIFORNIA CONSUMER PART.
OF PRIVACY ACT.
AND ONE GOAL OF THESE
CONVERSATIONS THERE ARE MANY
GOALS.
OF THE MODERNIZATION OF THE OF A
TRADITIONAL INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER'S.
AUTHORITY TO MODERNIZE IT
UPDATED AS MISTER CALDERON SAID.
IS A GOAL SECONDLY TO AVOID
REDUNDANCY AND ANY EFFICIENCY --
BETWEEN THOSE TWO DEPARTMENTS
THE DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE
WHICH HAS -- AND ENFORCEMENT
STAFF AND HAS  HISTORY
ALMOST FORTY YEARS ON THESE
TOPICS.
AND THEN THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
WHO NOW HAS NEW AUTHORITY ON THE
SUBJECT AND SO BALANCING THAT
OUT I THINK IT'S A VERY
LEGITIMATE.
ROLE FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO TO
BALANCE THAT OUT TO AVOID
REDUNDANCY AND INEFFICIENCIES
AND CONFUSION -- THERE IS A
SCENARIO THEY'LL BE TWO SETS OF
REGULATIONS WHICH DON'T AGREE
AND THAT WOULD BE THAT WOULD BE
BAD FOR CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS.
SO THESE CONVERSATIONS WILL
CONTINUE OUR STAFF HAS BEEN
DOING A GOOD JOB BRINGING PEOPLE
TOGETHER -- AND YOU KNOW MANY
BILLS WE INTRODUCE OUR FOR
PURPOSES OF ONGOING NEGOTIATIONS
AND DISCUSSION TO TRY TO REACH.
THE BEST POSSIBLE GOALS TRY TO
REACH CONSENSUS -- AS MISTER
CALDERON SAID THE CCPA WAS
APPROVED PRETTY.
THE PARTY HASTILY LAST YEAR --
AND MANY INDUSTRIES NOW ARE ARE
IN SOME SOME CHAOS BECAUSE THEY
HAVE TO NOW.
THE FIGURE OUT HOW TO COMPLY
WITH THE LAW.
AND PRE EXISTING LAW -- AS WELL --
I HAD A GOOD CONVERSATION WITH
MR MCTAGGART WHO IS THE AUTHOR
OF THE INITIATIVE.
THAT ENDED UP BECOMING LAW LAST
AUGUST AND I HAVE A LOT OF
RESPECT FOR HIS EFFORTS AND WE
HAD A VERY FRANK CONVERSATION
ABOUT THIS SUBJECT.
AS MISTER CALDERON SAID I THINK
THE REAL FOCUS OF THE INITIATIVE
WAS ON THE TECH INDUSTRY AND
OTHER INDUSTRIES IN CALIFORNIA
NOT NECESSARILY INSURANCE
HOWEVER INSURANCE IS A BIG
INDUSTRY WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THE NEW REGULATIONS WORK -- FOR
CONSUMERS AND WORK FOR THE
MARKET PLACE AS WELL --
OCCASIONALLY THIS THIS BUILDING
WILL WILL PASS A LAW THAT.
TO THE CAUSES RATES TO GO UP --
AND THAT'S THAT'S NOT GOOD
EITHER SO WE WANT A DYNAMIC
MARKET PLACE WE WANT FAIRNESS.
WE WANT CONSUMERS TO BE
EMPOWERED.
AND THAT'S THE GOAL OF THESE IN
THE OF THESE NEGOTIATIONS I
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS AND
YOUR STANCE AND YOUR ONGOING
PARTICIPATION WITH OUR STAFFS --
TO TRY.
TO REACH THE BEST POSSIBLE GOALS
HERE.
THANK YOU MS COME ALIVE THANK
YOU FOR I AM JUST WANT TO SAY
THAT I AM GOING TO BE SUPPORTING
THIS BILL AND I THINK WHERE
THERE ARE REGULATORY
DISCREPANCIES -- BETWEEN
ENTITIES LIKE THE CPA AND I I P.
P. A..
N. REDUNDANCIES AND DUPLICATION
INVARIABLY THE RESULT IS CHAOS
FOR CONSUMERS AND I THINK
ULTIMATELY THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO AVOID SO THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY FURTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM FROM
MEMBERS.
MR DAILY WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
AYE I THINK THAT MIGHT HAVE BEEN
YOUR CLOTHES A LITTLE BIT AGO IT
WAS MORE OR LESS ANY CLOTHES BUT
I WANT TO JUST AGAIN THANK ALL
THE PARTICIPANTS SO.
BOOK THOSE WHO HAVE RAISED
OBJECTIONS AND CONCERNS AS WELL
AS OF THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR
YOUR THOUGHTFUL PARTICIPATION IN --
WILL BE -- WILL BE HAVING
EXTENSIVE CONVERSATIONS FOR
MONTHS TO COME ON THIS -- WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN
AYE VOTE GREAT I'D ALSO WANTED
TO JUST SAY THAT -- I'M ALSO
SUPPORTING US TODAY I'M A STRONG
PRIVACY ADVOCATE -- BUT WE
CERTAINLY DON'T TO BE
DUPLICATIVE ONE BY AND ALSO
WANTED WITHOUT GOING FURTHER ONE
ECHO THE COMMENTS OF MY
COLLEAGUES I'LL BE SUPPORTING IT
THIS TODAY.
THE THIS CALL THE ROLL.
ON AB NINE EIGHTY ONE THE MOTION
IS TO DO PASS.
AS AMENDED PRIVACY AND CONSUMER
PROTECTION.
DALY AYE DALY AYE MAYES HI.
I BERMAN.
BERMAN AYE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW I CALDERON AYE CALDERON
AYE CHAN.
CHAN I CHU.
CHU AYE COOLEY.
COOPER.
COOPER I FRAZIER AYE FRAZIER AYE
GIPSON.
GIPSON I GRAYSON.
KAMLAGER-DOVE HI KAMLAGER-DOVE I
VOEPEL. ELEVEN ZERO ELEVEN IS
THERE THAT BILL IS -- IS OUT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN.
THANK YOU MISTER.
THANK YOU MISTER MAYES FOR A FOR
CHAIRING THE COMMITTEE -- WE
HAVE FINISHED OUR BUSINESS I'M
GONNA LEAVE THE HEARING OPEN SO
THAT FOLKS CAN ADD ON WE ALSO
NEED TO ADOPT THE COMMITTEE
RULES I NEGLECTED TO DO THAT SO
IS THERE A MOTION TO ADOPT THE
COMMITTEE RULES MOTION AND
SECOND.
ANY DISCUSSION ROLL CALL VOTE
PLEASE.
DALY AYE DALY AYE MAYES AYE
MAYES AYE BERMAN.
BIGELOW BIGELOW I CALLED RUN.
WALDRON I CHEN [inaudible] TWO
COOLEY.
UBER. TWO FOR AYE.
FRAZIER AYE FRAZIER AYE GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON.
KAMLAGER-DOVE HI KAMLAGER-DOVE I
VOEPEL.
THANK YOU TO THE COMMITTEE WAS A
GOOD HEARING AND THE RULES HAVE
BEEN APPROVED WITH THE MAJORITY
VOTE AND I THINK THE ONLY
MISSING MEMBERS MISTER VOEPEL.
DO WE WANT TO LEAVE THE AN OPEN
FROM -- YEAH.
LET'S GO AHEAD DO ADD ONS NOW
[inaudible]
CONSENT CALENDAR.
BIGELOW.
BIGELOW I GRACE.
VOEPEL.
THEN ITEM NUMBER.
SIX AB.
FIVE SIXTY SEVEN DO PASSED AGING
AND LONG TERM HERE.
GRAYSON.
VOEPEL THE PRESENT ON HIS
[inaudible] OH OKAY -- HE DID
OKAY -- LET ME MAKE SURE.
RELIEF EARLIER.
THANKS.
YOU'RE ON EVERYTHING
[inaudible] ELEVEN LEVIN.
THE TEN SIXTY FIVE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW I GRAYSON [inaudible]
VOEPEL.
AB ELEVEN OH FOUR BIGELOW.
BIGELOW I GRAYSON.
VOEPEL.
I GOT I GOT A COUPLE OF ONE SURE
YOU KNOW
-- PERCENT -- WHEN THEY
AB [inaudible]
SIXTEEN SEVENTY NINE I I THINK
YOU RUN.
I MISSED YOU I OKAY VERY GOOD
THANK YOU.
YEAH I'M GRAYSON WAS OFF ON
AMAZON VOEPEL WILL BE RIGHT HERE
JUST WRAP UP THAT STORYLINE TAKE
THAT BACK IF YOU TAKE THAT.
OFFICE ALTHOUGH TRIED.
OVER THERE WAS A LINE ON WE JUST
HIRED.
OKAY SO -- THE NUMBER OF FIVE
ONE YEAH WE HAD TALKED THEIR
WHOLE LIVES -- WORKS.
YEAH.
I DON'T KNOW.
THANK YOU.
I KNOW WHAT YOU'RE GONNA BOTH
HAD TO LISTEN [inaudible]
OKAY.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
GRAYSON BY GRAYSON AYE VOEPEL.
VOEPEL I THE FOURTEEN TO ZERO ON
EIGHTY FIVE SIXTY SEVEN THAT IS
TO PASS EIGHTEEN A LONG TERM
CARE -- GRAYSON.
GRAYSON I VOEPEL.
WHICH ONE FIVE SIXTY SEVEN FILE
ITEMS THAT [inaudible]
MISTER CALDERON [inaudible]
WELL [inaudible]
NO VOTE. THIRTEEN IS. ZERO EIGHT
NUMBER ITEM NUMBER SEVEN AB --
NINE THIRTY TWO VOEPEL.
VOEPEL I FOURTEEN TO ZERO ITEM
NUMBER.
EIGHT NINE EIGHTY ONE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON I VOEPEL.
HELL I FOURTEEN TO ZERO ON ITEM
NUMBER NINE AB.
TEN SIXTY FIVE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE VOEPEL.
VOEPEL I FOURTEEN TWO ZERO ON
ITEM NUMBER -- ELEVEN ELEVEN FOR
GRAYSON.
GRAYSON I VOEPEL.
VOEPEL I FOURTEEN ZERO AND I'M
ITEM THIRTEEN AB SIXTEEN SEVENTY
NINE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON I VOEPEL.
VOEPEL I FOURTEEN TO ZERO AND
THE THE CONCEPT WHEN I WALKED IN
YEAH YEAH.
OKAY EVERYBODY ON EVERYTHING
THAT.
WOULD.
VOTE ON THE THREE IMPORTANT.
READ THE THREE WAS PULLED.
AND I'M A POOR WITH ONE CONSENT.
OKAY GOT IT THANK YOU